THERE.
WE JUST HAD AN OFFICIALLY CALLED
OURSELVES TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
WELCOME TO THIS MORNING'S
HEARING OF THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SIXTEEN BILLS
THERE WE GO NOW WE'RE REALLY ON
SIXTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON CONSENT.
WE WILL LIMIT TESTIMONY TO TWO
PEOPLE TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES MAY
STATE THEIR NAME AND THEIR
ORGANIZATION OF WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE ITEM WE'RE
GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SENATOR
DORADO FOR BEING HERE MUCH
APPRECIATED.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL START WITH
OUR FIRST AUTHOR MISTER JONES
SAWYER WHICH IS ITEM.
TO AB TWO FIFTY EIGHT BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT A BILL THAT WOULD USE
FUNDS FROM PROP SIXTY FOUR YEAR
MARK FOR TREATMENT AND
PREVENTION.
TO FUND SUSTAINABLE HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL SUPPORT
SERVICES THE GRANTS CREATED BY
THIS BILL WILL HELP FILL THE
VOID IN A NUMBER OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES STAFF.
ALLEVIATE THE WORKLOAD OF
ALREADY OVERWORKED TEACHERS AND
CONNECT SCHOOLS TO EXISTING
COMMUNITY RESOURCES.
THE BILL IS STRUCTURED SUCH THAT
GRANTS TO LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY A
50% FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR
MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE SERVICE.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL IS CLEAR
AS EVIDENCED IN THE TEACHER
STRIKES WE HAVE SEEN ACROSS THIS
STATE.
EDUCATORS STATEWIDE HAVE MADE
CLEAR THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
CURRENT RATIOS OF SUPPORT STAFF
ARE TERRIBLE WITH ONE COUNSEL
FOR EVERY EIGHT SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY ONE STUDENTS ONE NURSE
FOR EVERY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS AND ONE SOCIAL
WORKER FOR EVERY NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS.
OUR STUDENTS ARE FACING.
STRESS AND TRAUMA AT
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS WITHOUT
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES STAFF.
AND PROGRAMS ON CAMPUS TO ATTEND
THE THESE NEEDS WE CANNOT
POSSIBLY EXPECT OUR STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED.
THIS BILL PROVIDES GRANTS THAT
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ON WHAT SERVICES BEST
BIT THE NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
FOR SOME THIS MAY MEAN TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. FOR OTHERS
TRAINING FOR TEACHERS IN
IDENTIFYING STUDENTS IN NEED OF
TREATMENT. FOR OTHERS THE
CREATION OF A SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTER MIGHT BE THE MOST
SUPPORTIVE.
WHICH STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH
THE SUPPORT OF SERVICES STAFF
THAT THEY NEED WE SEE INCEASE
CLASSROOM ENGAGEMENT BETTER
ATTENDANCE IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS AND MOST IMPORTANT
REDUCED DRUG USAGE RATES.
GRAHAM IS MODELED AFTER A
SIMILAR -- SOME REALLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN COLORADO
WHICH ALSO SAW IT PICKED UP
HEALTH PROGRAM RESULT IN BETTER
PEOPLE DISCIPLINE DATA AS WELL
AS SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
DECREASING AFTER IMPLEMENTATION
WE OWE IT TO OUR STUDENTS TO PUT
THEM IN THE BEST POSSIBLE
POSITION TO SUCCEED. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IS
HELEN HELEN THOUSAND FROM
TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY STICK
HEALTHY KIDS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY OWNAGE
GIRL NOT HELEN DOWN WITH
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
ONE OF THE COAST.
CO SPONSORS F THE BILL JUST
VERY QUICKLY WE BELIEVE THAT
ULTIMATELY THERE WILL BE SIX
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES.
IN THIS FUN.
TOO FIGHT A VARIETY OF SERVICES
INCLUDING CHILD CARE -- AS WE
GET.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IT INTO THE
PROGRAM AND THAT'S WHY CTA IS
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE IN AND
LIVE IN HOPES OF INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICE PERSONNEL ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. ONE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION -- I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS I WOULD ONLY BRIEFLY
SAY OUR SCHOOLHOUSE ISSUE IS
ASSESSED ESSENTIALLY A HIDDEN
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
AND WE BELIEVE WITH THE ADVENT
OF THIS GRANT PROGRAMS THAT -- I
THINK WE'LL HAVE A A LARGER
PICTURE ABOUT WHAT KINDS ISSUES
CORN AND SCHOOL THE FACT THAT WE
NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SERVICES
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT KIDS DOING WELL IN SCHOOL
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BETTER TEST
SCORES.
THEY NEED THE SUPPORT SERVICES
AND SO WE ARE.
ARE VERY PROUD TO BE THE CO
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ERIC OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THE FUNDING AND THIS WILL
PROVIDE WILL DEFINITELY HELP OUR
STUDENTS AND WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE MORE ADULTS WITHIN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM. TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF KIDS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LEE ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MORE SECONDS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
COME RIGHT ON UP [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
MIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- TOM RENT FREE WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA -- WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE THE INTENT OF THIS BILL WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED AT SOME
LENGTH WITH THE AUTHORS STAFF --
THE FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE%
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WORKING IN THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE SOME EXPERTISE OR
ADEQUATE TRAINING IN SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER PREVENTION -- THE
THE CURRENT.
IN THE CURRENT FORM.
THERE'S A DESCRIPTION OF THE
SCHOOL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL MEANS
AN INDIVIDUAL HOLDING A SERVICES
CREDENTIAL WITH A SPECIALIZATION
IN PUPIL PERSONNEL SERVICES.
OR SERVICES CREDENTIAL WITH A
SPECIALIZATION IN HEALTH FOR A
SCHOOL NURSE BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY HAVE ANY
SPECIALIZED TRAINING IN
ENVIRONMENTAL PRIMARY OR
SECONDARY SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PREVENTION WHICH IS AN
ESTABLISHED FIELD OF WORK IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT RELATES TO A SECOND
CONCERN.
WE THINK IT WOULD BE BETTER IF
THE BILL LEVERAGE CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
PREVENTION INFRASTRUCTURE
CERTIFIED THE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PREVENTION SPECIALISTS
ARE ALREADY ACTIVE IN MANY
SCHOOLS -- WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
LANGUAGE ENCOURAGING THESE
PROGRAMS TO COORDINATE WITH
EXISTING PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
RATHER THAN CREATING A SEPARATE
STRUCTURE WHICH BYPASSES THE
GOOD PREVENTION WORK THAT'S
ALREADY -- BEING DONE AND WE
THINK THAT WOULD MAKE FOR A MORE
EFFECTIVE USE OF THE PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR FUNDS.
HAVING SAID ALL THAT WE HAVE AN
OVER OVER AN HOUR LONG A
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
STAFF YESTERDAY I THOUGHT IT WAS
IT WAS HELPFUL AND PRODUCTIVE --
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE THE
WORK THAT AND THEM WORKING WITH
US -- TO TRIED TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH THEM THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
PROCEED MEXICO.
THE OF MIXING MANTLE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND WE CONCUR WITH
MISTER ENTRIES COMMENTS AND AT
THIS TIME WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS WE HAVE A QORUM AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE WILK PRESIDENT WILL
CARE CHIANG DO ASAL.
MULA SO HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN HERE.
GOOD WE HAVE A QUORUM ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SENATOR
TORONTO.
IS JUST A FOLLOW UP WITH THE
LAST -- REMARKS THAT WERE MADE.
DO YOU SEE THE THAT -- THAT
CONCERN COULD BE FIXED.
YEAH IN THIS LEGISLATION.
LET ME JUST START WITH ONE I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN NOW PRECLUDES ON ANY OF
THAT FROM HAPPENING -- WE WANT
TO WORK WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE STRENGTH IN THAT -- LET
ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE IN MY
DISTRICT AT FREMONT HIGH SCHOOL
THERE'S A HEALTH CENTER CALL
MMHM.
WHICH IS BOTH THE COUNTY.
AND SCHOOL RESOURCES COMEY
TOGETHER ON ONE CAMPUS PROVIDING
DRUG REHABILITATION SERVICES FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN SERVICE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND THEY ALL HAVE
BROUGHT THOSE ON CAMPUS.
THAT'S MY VISION FOR WHAT THIS
ULTIMATELY WILL BE IT WILL BE.
WE CANNOT EXCLUDE THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSION WE CAN'T
EXCLUDE THE DRUG REHABILITATION
INDIVIDUALS ON OUR CAMPUS WE
NEED TO COME TOGETHER AND MAKE
THIS HAPPEN AND AND SO I WILL
WORK VERY CLOSELY. TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENED BECAUSE AS YOU
KNOW SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
ARE WE EXPERIENCE EVERY.
TYPE OF AILMENT POSSIBLE.
IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
AND BECAUSE OF THE BUDGET CUTS
BEFORE WE GOT HERE.
WE JUST TOTALLY DECIMATED AT
THAT THAT SUPPORT SERVICES I'M
JUST TRYING TO USE MONEY TO
BUILD IT BACK UP AGAIN AND I
DEFINITELY WE CANNOT DO IT
WITHOUT COUNTY RESOURCES EITHER.
JUST A FOLLOW UP -- YEAH.
I APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE
THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY DOING IT
BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE OTHERS.
ARE AND I'M NOT SAYING THERE
THERE'S ANYTHING YOU KNOW BAD
ABOUT THE MORE THAT BAD
INTENTIONS IT JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN UNLESS.
THEY'RE NUDGED OR PUSHED IN THAT
DIRECTION SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT
I GOT OUT OF THE REMARKS OF
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND NOW I THINK YOU AS
A MEMBER JONES SAWYER FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORD I WAS ACTUALLY
FOR USE THE THE MEDICAL
CONSULTANTS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE SCHOOL
NURSES AND PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SO
FORTH AND HOW IMPORTANT IS TO
BRING THESE THINGS ON CAMPUS AS
YOU SAID I CERTAINLY -- HERE THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION IN
TERMS OF SAYING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT ALSO WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT IS IS THAT -- NO WE
DO NEED AS I THINK THE SELLER
SAID -- TO NOT TO SAY WHAT LAMBS
IS THEY'LL REFER PEOPLE OUT
BECAUSE SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T
MAKE IT THERE WE NEED TO BRING
THINGS LIKE CAMPUS SCHOOLS OUR
COMMUNITY CENTERS -- SO WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE HOW TO BETTER
INTEGRATE IN FACT ONE OF THE
THINGS I I WORKED ON AS MEDICAL
CONSULTANT WAS ACTUALLY FIGURE
OUT HOW WE BETTER INTEGRATE THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHAT THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM RIGHT -- SOMETIMES
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT DOESN'T
REALLY HAPPEN AND I THINK THIS
WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AYE -- I GUESS THE
QUESTION DOES THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS IS THAT -- ARE YOU
BASED -- YOU CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO SEE WHAT
WE CAN TRY TO DO TO ACHIEVE THE
VISION HAT YOU EXPRESSED.
YES I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM BUT IT IS JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT.
LANGUAGE THAT GIVES BOTH SIDES
COMFORT OKAY WELL I FIRST START
WAS LAST NIGHT AND AND HOPEFULLY
WE GET SOMETHING FAIRLY QUICKLY.
OKAY WELL I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO ANSWERING A
SUPPORT THE BILL AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO'S WANTS TO
TRY TO BRING EVERYONE TOGETHER.
AND SO -- I I CERTAINLY HAVE
FULL CONFIDENCE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THAT AND CERTAINLY
WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL WILL
MOVE THE BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN IN THE
OTHER THING OKAY VERY GOOD SO
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AND AND I WANNA THANK YOU WITH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
AND AND I GENERALLY DO BELIEVE.
THAT THE ONLY WAY THIS WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL IS EVERYONE FROM
EVERY SECTOR COME TOGETHER TO TO
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN -- IF WE HAVE SILOS WERE
SENDING PEOPLE OUT -- THAT COULD
BE VERY PROBLEMATIC AND SO WE WE
HAVE TO COME UP AND EACH WE HAVE.
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY DISTRICT IS
GONNA HAVE TO COME UP WITH A A
METHODOLOGY TO MAKE SENSE FOR
THEM.
WE NEED TO INCORPORATE AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LEAVE ANY
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL OUT
WHATSOEVER.
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWO AB TWO FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHANGED TO
WRESTLE WITH US SO I GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES WE BELIEVE
IT ON CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES.
COME ON UP.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS TODAY.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR A LOT ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY
THREE TODAY
TODAY PART TIME FACULTY MAKE
THAT THE MAJORITY OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTRUCTORS NATIONWIDE
SPECIFICALLY AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THERE IS AN
ESTIMATED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND I
CHEN PROVIDE FACULTY COMPARED TO
NINETEEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
INSTRUCTORS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY RELIANT UPON PART
TIME I CHEN FACULTY WHO FACE LOW
PAY A FEW BENEFITS A MINIMAL JOB
SECURITY.
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY ARE MOST AFFECTED BY
REQUIREMENTS TO HOLD ADVANCED
DEGREES BECAUSE SUCH AS MASTER'S
AND PHD IS AS A RESULT THEY BEAR
HEAVY BURDEN OF STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
MOREOVER MANY AYE CHEN FACULTY
MUST WORK THE EQUIVALENT FULL
TIME HOURS BUT ACROSS MULTIPLE
INSTITUTIONS THIS INCIDENT
HINDERS THEIR ABILITY -- OF THEM
TO BENEFIT FROM THE FEDERAL
PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM.
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO ELIMINATE
THE BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE THAT
PREVENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY A MANY OF THESE PART
TIME AYE CHEN FACULTY FROM
APPLYING TO THIS PROGRAM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO CREDIT PART TIME
FACULTY IN PLACE WITH.
THREE POINT THREE FIVE HOURS I
WORKED FOR EACH HOUR OF LECTURE
OR CLASSROOM TIME MAKING EASIER
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBERS TO QUALIFY
FOR THE PROGRAM.
BY REMOVING THE ECONOMIC BARRIER
THAT CURRENTLY PREVENTS THEM
FROM SSE IN THE FEDERAL LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM THIS WILL
ADDRESS THE TEACHER SHORTAGE BY
ENCOURAGING COLLEGE GRADUATES TO
SEEK CAREERS IN PUBLIC SERVICE
AND PUBLIC HIGHER.
EDUCATION IT IS A CRITICAL THAT
WE ASSIST EDUCATORS WHO DEDICATE
THEIR LIVES EVERY DAY TO THEIR
STUDENTS.
POLICY IN THIS BILL IS
IMPERATIVE TO HELPING OUR PART
TIME FACULTY WILL GIVE OUR
EDUCATORS A FIGHTING CHANCE JUST
TO APPLY FOR THIS FEDERAL LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY IS RON RAP BUT
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAP ON THE
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE ARE
PROUD SPONSORS OF AB.
FOUR SIX THREE AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
FOR LEADERSHIP AROUND STUDENT
THAT -- AS MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW
STUDENT DEBT IN THIS COUNTRY IS
ESTIMATED AT ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION DOLLARS IT IS MORE THAN
CREDIT CARD DEBT AND CAR LOANS
IT WOULD BE IT WOULD RANK NUMBER
THIRTEEN IN TERMS OF GDP.
IF WE CALCULATED IT THAT WAY.
IT IS THE NEXT FINANCIAL CRISIS
IN AMERICA.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT SURVEY OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE A. F. T. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE AVERAGE
STUDENT DEBT FOR GRADUATE IS
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ALTHOUGH PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY THAT I SPOKE TO
HAVE MUCH HIGHER DEBT GIVEN THE
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE AN ADVANCED
DEGREE -- CONGRESS PASSED THE
THE FEDERAL PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN TO PROVIDE
FORGIVENESS OF CERTAIN TYPES OF
STUDENT LOANS FOR GRADUATES WHO
WOULD WHO AGREED TO WORK IN
PUBLIC SERVER SERVICE OVER TEN
YEARS AND MAKE TEN YEARS WORTH
OF PAYMENTS.
UNDER CERTAIN LOAN'S REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS EDUCATORS WERE INCLUDED
IN THIS CATEGORY.
AB FOUR SIX THREE IS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ADDRESSES THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG AS IT RELATES
TO STUDENT DEBT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PART TIME FACULTY.
THEY DEDICATE THEIR LIVES TO
STUDENTS IN THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN THE
COUNTRY YET THEY'RE PAID
SUBSTANDARD WAGES IN MOST CASES
THEY DO NOT RECEIVE BENEFITS.
AND DO NOT RECEIVE CREDIT FOR
THE HOURS THEY SPEND OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM PREPARING LESSONS
MEETING WITH STUDENTS -- GRADING
PAPERS THUS THEY DON'T QUALIFY
FOR THE P. SLF PROGRAM.
AB FOUR SIX THREE IS WRITTEN TO
PROVIDE THESE PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY WITH
THE FEDERAL BENEFIT THAT WILL
HELP THEM STAY IN A PROFESSION
THEY HAVE CHOSEN ARE PASSIONATE
ABOUT.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE PART TIME
FACULTY ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM AND A
GATEWAY TO OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM --
I WANT TO RE TO JUST A COUPLE OF
VIGNETTES FROM A COUPLE OF OUR
MEMBERS THEY WROTE LETTERS OF
SUPPORT. FOR A BI FOUR SIX THREE
THESE ARE THESE ARE
HEARTBREAKING -- STORIES THIS IS
TAMMY I HAVE OVER A HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN
DEBT YET I DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
THE P. SLA PER P. SLF PROGRAM.
AS A SINGLE PARENT OF A DISABLED
CHILD I STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET WORKING TWO PART TIME TO
PART TIME JOBS IN TWO DIFFERENT
CAMPUSES MAKES IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE PRICE OF GAS
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME A PERSONAL
UNPAID TIME ON SCHOOL RELATED
PROJECTS AND WORKING WITH MY
STUDENTS -- VALERIE CURRENTLY I
OWE A HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOANS.
THE BALANCES BLOOM BECAUSE THERE
WERE TIMES HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE THE PAYMENT SO I RESORTED
TO FORBEARANCE IS AND HAVE HAD
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL FOR
ADDITIONAL DEGREES FOR WORK
PURPOSES.
MY STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS EXCEED
MY MORTGAGE PAYMENTS AT THIS
POINT.
I SEE NO WAY OF PAYING OFF MY
DEBT I LOSE A LOT OF SLEEP OVER
THIS ISSUE I AM FIFTY FOUR YEARS
OLD -- AND I WORK TWO JOBS IN
ORDER TO TO MAKE MY PAYMENTS --
ON MY LOAN -- IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ONE MEMBER
WROTE AN AYE VOTE ON A BEFORE
SIX THREE TELLS US AS PART TIME
FACULTY.
THAT WE ARE VALUED FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM AN AYE VOTE ON A.
B. FOUR SIX THREE WILL GIVE US
AS PART TIME FACULTY A HAND UP
TOWARDS SECURING THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR ECONOMIC.
SURVIVAL WE RESPECTFULLY
ASTRONAUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A JUST
HEART BREAKING STORIES AND WE
CAN DO BETTER.
WE CAN DO BETTER -- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTES I THINK THAT WE CAN DO
MUCH BETTER FOR OUR PART TIME I
JEFF BAKUL.
TO BY THE DESERVE MORE AND TO
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN DO THAT.
VERY GOOD TANK YOU THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THREE AB FOR SIXTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK.
WILK I CHANGED TO WRESTLE.
WITH US ALL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE
PAN PAN AYE.
AS FOR VOTES AND LEAVE IT OPEN
BELIEVE IT ON CALL AND YOU HAVE
ALSO ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS
AB SEVEN TEN BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SUFFER LONG ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TEN
TODAY ALSO WANT TO THANK AYE
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS BILL. ONE
OF THE BIGGEST COMPONENT OF THE
INCREASING COST TO RECEIVE A
HIGH QUALITY POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IS THE COST OF HOUSING.
IN THE RECENT YEARS A COST TO
ATTEND COLLEGE HAS GROWN FOUR
TIMES THE RATE OF INFLATION.
AB SEVEN TEN SIX TO ENSURE THAT
HOUSING COSTS FIGURES ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE ACTUAL FINANCIAL
NEED OF THE STUDENT AT THAT
INSTITUTION.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT DATA AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE COST OF
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS NOTHING
MORE NOTHING LESS THE DATA WE
PROVIDE TO STUDENTS ON THE
PERSPECTIVE COST OF ATTENDANCE
IF.
EXCUSE ME INFLUENCES OF THEIR
CHOICE I THEY MAKE ABOUT WHICH
COLLEGE THEY DECIDE TO ATTEND
WHETHER OR NOT TO TAKE OUT LOANS
TO PAY FOR THAT COLLEGE FOR THE
HIGHER EDUCATION OR TO PURSUE.
A HIGHER EDUCATION AT ALL.
UNDER EXISTING LAW THERE IS NO
STANDARD NO SYSTEM WIDE PROCESS
TO CALCULATE HOUSING COSTS AT
ANY HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTION
COLLEGES HAVE CONSIDERABLE
DISCRETION IN THIS CATEGORY.
WELL CS I WASI SACK HAS
CONDUCTED A PILOT STUDENT EXACT --
EXPENSE AND RESOURCE SURVEY
OTHER NINE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
SEARS FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THERE'S NO LEGAL REQUIREMENT FOR
INSTITUTIONS TO USE THAT DATA OR
OTHER SURVEYS AT ALL.
FURTHERMORE THE STATE'S STUDENT
EXPENSE AND RESOURCE SURVEYS
HAVE NOT BEEN ACTIVE FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE.
THE LAST YEAR'S UPDATE WAS IN
TWENTY EIGHT TWO THOUSAND SIX
AND SEVEN SCHOOL YEAR ACADEMIC
SCHOOL YEAR THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
THAT SEARS WILL BE REINSTATED BY
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION OR
THAT IT WILL STAY ACTIVE IN THE
STATE IF THE STATE ENCOUNTERS
DIFFICULT BUDGETARY CHALLENGES
IN THE FUTURE.
SURVEYS ALSO I DO NOT PROVIDE AN
ACCURATE ACCURATE REFLECTION OF
THE RESOURCES STUDENTS ACTUALLY
NEED TO ATTEND COLLEGE THEY
OFTEN PRESENT A DISTORTED IMAGE
OF WHAT STUDENTS ACTUALLY SPEND
WHEN THEY ARE FORCED TO DO --
MAKE DO WITH HE RESOURCES THE
LIMITED RESOURCES THE COLLEGE
STUDENTS ALREADY HAVE A LOT OF
THEM ARE FOOD IN SECURE -- MANY
GO TO EVENTS WHERE THERE IS FREE
FOOD AND CARPOOL LANE IN ORDER
TO AVOID TRANSPORTATION COSTS.
ARE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING SHOULD BE UPDATING
THEIR HOUSING COSTS ON A
FREQUENT BASIS IN ORDER TO KEEP
UP WITH THE STATE'S EVER
FLUCTUATING MARKET HOUSING
MARKET.
AB SEVEN TEN WILL HELP ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY REQUIRING
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
TO USE THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT --
DEVELOPMENTS MARKET FOR MARKET
RATES I WHICH IS ACTUALLY VERY
RELIABLE AND CONSISTENTLY
PUBLISHED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
FIVE TO THE FAIR MARKET RENT
SYSTEM FOR THE FOR OVER FORTY
FIVE YEARS THIS IS BEEN IN PLACE
THE FOR MARKET RENT DOUBT IS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND MORE
ACCURATELY PORTRAYS THE COST OF
HOUSING AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES.
NOT ONLY IS A FAIR MARKET RATE
DATA MORE ACCURATE RELIABLY.
UPDATED BUT USING ONE STANDARD
TO CALCULATE COST OF HOUSING
WILL ALLOW STUDENTS TO MAKE
BETTER COST COMPARISONS BETWEEN
INSTITUTE.
INSTITUTIONS WHEN CHOOSING WHICH
COLLEGE TO ATTEND.
AB SEVEN TEN WILL HELP ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR
HAVE MORE ACCURATE PICTURE OF A
FINANCIAL RESOURCE THEY WILL
MAKE.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THEIR
COMMENCEMENTS ARE WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
IS MANY RODRIGUEZ -- EXCUSE ME
AS MANY MERGING GUESTS FROM THE
EDUCATION TRUST WES AND ALSO
ADAM HAVE JAFFE FOR A STUDENT
FROM UC DAVIS.
GREAT SO UNDER COMMITTEE RULES
TO SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES IN THIS
BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT.
AND MANY OF THE MORNING
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
LIKE ON OKAY WE'RE NOT GONNA
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM YOUR TIME RIGHT.
BENEVOLENT CHAIR WELL THAT'S
GREAT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS OUT OF
MODESTY I'M AN UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT FROM UC DAVIS -- I'M A
FINANCIAL AID RECIPIENT AND I AM
ALSO THE XO WHAT'S PRESIDENT FOR
THE UC DAVIS IN ASSOCIATION ON
THE OFFICIAL REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE UC DAVIS OTHER OF SENATOR OF
THE YOU SEE OF SOMEBODY -- I'M
HERE TO TED TODAY TO TELL YOU
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN MANY MONTHS
WHERE I LOOKED AT MY BILL AND
THOUGHT TO MYSELF MY GOD.
I'M NOT GONNA MAKE MY RENT THIS
MONTH THANKFULLY THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED YET A RECENT SURVEY AT
UC DAVIS SHOWED THAT 18% OF
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN HOUSING AND
SECURE.
AND 7% HAVE EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS AND WHEN I WAS
LOOKING AT THOSE NUMBERS I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF.
I'M ONE OF THOSE THAT 18% AND
THE THOUGHT OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
PAY MY RENT ONE MONTH IS.
TERRIFYING TO ME -- AND THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS THAT TO US TO
IN STATE STUDENTS RECEIVE
FINANCIAL AID HOUSING IS THE
BIZARRE BIGGEST COSTS OF IT
BIGGEST CONSUMMATE IN ATTENDANCE --
OP I PAY MORE THAN A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR SINGLE ROOM
IN A FOUR BEDROOM APARTMENT --
I'VE SPOKEN TO PEOPLE I
REPRESENTED UC DAVIS WHO HAVE.
NO INCOME -- CAN GET NO HELP
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AND THEY
HAVE CONSIDERED DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS MY
OWN ROOMMATE.
HAS MOVED GRADUATED RECENTLY
TOLD ME THAT HE CONSIDERED
DROPPING OUT AT LEAST FIVE OR
SIX TIMES BECAUSE OF HOUSING
COSTS -- AND KNOWING WHAT WE'RE
GETTING OURSELVES INTO A KNOWING
WHAT THE COST OF OUR HOUSING IS
GOING TO BE ONE WERE SIGNING UP
FOR OUR FOR FOR FOR THE
UNIVERSITY -- AND THAT THAT
COULD MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN
AND HOW WE PROCEED WITH OUR
EDUCATION -- AND THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE TODAY.
IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED GOOD MORNING BY
SIR WILK AND SAID EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY RODRIGUEZ
FROM THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST --
TODAY WERE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR AB SEVEN TEN A BILL
THAT WILL ENSURE ACCURATE FAIR
CONSISTENT HOUSING BY UTILIZING
FAIR AND AND HOUSING URBAN
DEVELOPMENT DATA.
AS OPPOSED OUTDATED SURVEY
SURVEY.
ET W BELIEVES THAT THIS
TRANSPARENCY IN ACCURACY IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR ALL
STUDENTS BUT PARTICULARLY.
FIRST HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES WHO
MIGHT NOT HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER
OR FRIEND WHO CAN HELP THEM
NAVIGATE -- AFFORDING COLLEGE.
IF OUR HIGHER ED INSTITUTIONS
NOT DISCLOSE ACCURATE
INFORMATION TO OUR STUDENTS AND
PARENTS ON THE COST OF LIVING IN
AN AREA.
THEIR ULTIMATELY LEFT AT THE
MERCY OF THOSE INSTITUTIONS
INFORMATIONS AND STUDENTS WHO
CAN BE MOST HARMED OR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND OTHER HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS.
THIS BILL IS A STEP FORWARD TO
HELP OUR STUDENTS AND PARENTS
ACCESS ACCURATE DATA ENSURING
THAT.
WE ARE NOT UNDERESTIMATING OR
OVERESTIMATING THE COSTS COLLEGE.
IS FOR THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK BROUGH.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SAYING THAT ANY OF OUR OWN
SURGERY SO THE CAR REPRESENTING
THE CALL SIX IN ASSOCIATION WITH
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S ALWAYS.
ONE NO IT'S FINE KNOW WHAT THIS
OF I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT.
IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
STATE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
PLEASE PROCEED -- ALEX GRAYS
WITH THE ICC REPRESENT THE
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES
IN THE STATE AND WE DON'T HAVE
AYE OPPOSED POSITION AT THIS
TIME WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WHEN IT THANK HEIR STAFF
FOR THAT TIME BUT WE DO HAVE.
A FEW CONCERNS I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ON THIS BILL -- I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE
QUESTION FOR US IS IS IS THE
GOAL OF THIS THIS POLICY
CONSISTENCY -- ACCURACY AND WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS WOUD
CREATE A CONSISTENT MECHANISM
FOR HOUSEHOLDS HAVE TO CALCULATE
HOUSING BUT WE DON'T BELIEVE.
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE MORE
ACCURATE -- YOU KNOW OUR SCHOOLS
DO WORK HARD TO SET THIS
ACCURATELY WERE REQUIRED UNDER
FEDERAL RAGS TO TO SET IT IS
ACTUALLY POSSIBLE FOR THE ACTUAL
LIVING CONDITION OF WHERE
STUDENTS GO TO SCHOOL -- AND YOU
KNOW I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE TWO
EXAMPLES I THINK HIGHLIGHT ARE
CONCERNED WITH PERHAPS THE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS.
SO.
UNDER THIS BILL -- ALL OUR
INSTITUTIONS IN LA COUNTY WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS IN
LA COUNTY WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
USE THE SAME HIGH DATA POINT AND
SETTING.
HOUSING A CALC ACOSTA TENANTS
JUST BE CLEAR THIS IS SETTING
BECAUSE WE TEND TO THE CEILING.
THE OUR SCHOOLS CAN PROVIDE
EIGHT UP TO THAT POINT WE CAN'T
PROVIDED BEYOND THAT.
SO THAT WOULD MEAN THAT FOR ALL
OUR SCHOOLS LA COUNTY -- WE
WOULD HAVE TO USE A FIGURE ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR DOLLARS THAT WOULD APPLY TO
OUR SCHOOLS IN MALIBU IN WITH
HERE IN PASADENA AND EVERYWHERE
ELSE IN BETWEEN THE COUNTY -- IN
OUR SCHOOLS ARE CONCERNED THEY
ESPECIALLY LOOKING AT THE LOCAL
HOUSING CONTACTS IN THE REGION
THERE AND THAT THAT NUMBER MIGHT
NOT BE THE MOST ACCURATE MEASURE.
IN A COUNTY'S LARGEST LA.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE -- IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY THAT FIGURE WOULD BE NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS FOR A
ONE BEDROOM -- HOUSING AT LAST
YEAR WHICH IS ONE REMEMBER
INSTITUTIONS ARE CURRENTLY USING
A NUMBER OF ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE DOLLARS -- SO
IN ESSENCE WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF AID BY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
DOLLARS PER MONTH AT OUR SCHOOLS
COULD PROVIDE.
STUDENTS -- IN THAT AREA -- NET
EFFECT BEING ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS LESS AN AIDE PER
YEAR AND YOU KNOW THERE ARE YOU
KNOW WE'RE DECENTRALIZED SYSTEM
SO WE'RE USING A NUMBER
MECHANISM SOME SCHOOLS LOOK AT
SEARS AND JUST UPDATE HAVE BEEN
UPDATING FOR INFLATION.
SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS ARE ARE
ANXIOUSLY AWAITING THE NEW SEARS
DATA WHICH IS GOING TO BE MORE
NUANCED AND LOCALIZED.
OTHERS LOOK AT LOCAL HOUSING
SURVEYS I EVEN OTHER SURVEYS
WITH AND HIDE IT FOR EXAMPLE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TALK ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT VARIATION WITHIN
REGIONS -- YOU KNOW WHETHER
YOU'RE RIGHT NEXT TO A CAMPUS OR
WHETHER YOU'RE IN A MORE RURAL
AREA SO THOSE ARE OUR CONCERNS
WE CERTAINLY YOU KNOW WORK HARD
TO SET THIS IS ACCURATELY AS
POSSIBLE CAUSES IMPLICATIONS FOR
STUDENTS -- BUT THAT WE WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THAT THIS IS
GOING TO LIMIT THEIR FLEXIBILITY
TO CONSIDER LOCAL CONTACTS AND
SET THAT NUMBER ACCURATELY
THANKS.
I FELT LIKE YOU FOR SECOND.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
CASINO TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
AND CONCERNS.
SENATOR DRAWS.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS SOME.
THIS FORWARD COULD YOU RESPOND
TO THE ISSUES RAISED -- ACTUALLY
OUT MY QUESTION WAS A LITTLE BIT
SIMILAR BUT I WAS GONNA ASK YOU
TO GIVE ME A EXAMPLE OF A
CONCRETE WAY IN WHICH THIS
CHANGE.
HOW WOULD THAT ACTUALLY IN A
VERY SPECIFIC WAY HELP?
STUDENTS UP BECAUSE I'LL HEAR
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT IT
COULD ACTUALLY HURT.
US STUDENTS AND I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE DOING IT WITH MALICE SIR --
TRYING TO FIND SOMETHING WRONG
SO COULD YOU THEY'RE SORT OF
CONNECTED THERE UP STORY THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE DONE VERY THOROUGH
RESEARCH ON MANY INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS THE STATE LOOKING AT THE
UC DATA AND CAL STATE DATA FOR
EXAMPLE HOW WE COMPARE THE UC
COST OF ATTENDANCE FIGURES FOR
OFF AGAIN THIS IS JUST FOR OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING -- OFF HAS OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING COSTS TO YOU SEE
YOU THROUGH THE CSU SYSTEM I
NEAR OR THE SAME COUNTY SAME
REGION -- SO THAT WE CAN FIND
COMPARISONS WE FOUND OUT THAT.
WITHIN THE SEVEN COMPARISONS
THAT WE DID ARGUE LOOK AT
BERKELEY EAST BAY SANTA CRUZ
MONTEREY BAY I RIVERSIDE SAMBAR
DINO SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO -- TWO
CAMPUSES BURKE CLEAN UC SAN
DIEGO HAVE HIGHER THAN THE CS
USE OFF CAMPUS HOUSING FIGURES
BALL THE OTHER FIVE HAVE LOWER
OFF CAMPUS HOUSING THAN THE
LOCAL CSU'S.
SO WE DO SEE DISCREPANCIES I'M
EVEN BETWEEN THE UC'S AND THE CS
USE THAT ARE LITERALLY JUST
MILES APART FROM EACH OTHER.
AND SO WHAT WE WIND TO IS THAT
WE WANT JUST TO HAVE AN ACCURATE
ASSESSMENTS TO STUDENTS CAN MAKE
THE BEST FINANCIAL -- CHOICE
WHEN IT AFFECTS IT COULD -- YOU
KNOW.
THE FACT HOW MUCH ONCE A TAKE
OUT.
DO THEY NEED TO TAKE OUT MORE
LOANS DO THEY TAKE OUT LESS
LOANS AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
WANT TO ADDRESS STUDENT DEBT WE
DON'T WANT STUDENTS TO INCUR
MORE DEBT THAN NEEDED -- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE WANT THEM TO
GET A STRONG FINANCIAL PACKAGE --
THAT COULD HELP THEM COVER THESE
COSTS AND WHEN THEY'RE DECIDING
WHICH INSTITUTION TO GO TO THEY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT WILL MY
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE COVER WHAT
WHAT I NEED TO PAY.
OUT OF POCKET AND THEN TURNING --
TO STUDENT LOANS AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE THAT'S ALREADY
A CRISIS THAT WE FACE NATION
WIDE SO AFTER DOING THOROUGH
RESEARCH -- WE FOUND OUT THE
FEDERAL HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT HAS CREATED THIS
FAIR MARKET RATE EACH YEAR SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR UPDATING
THAT LIST -- BECAUSE SEVERAL
SERVICES RELY ON THIS HIGH DATA
ALREADY ACROSS THE NATION AND
ITS UPDATED ANNUALLY WITH CENSUS
TRACKS AT ITS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
TO ANYONE.
I SO YOU DON'T AYE WE HAVE
ACTUALLY SPOKEN -- TO THE
OPPOSITION AT LANES AND WERE
ALWAYS OPEN AND WILLING TO
FIGURE OUT A PATH FORWARD OR IF
THERE ISN'T AN EASY NESS WHERE
THEY FILLED IT STUDENTS WOULD BE
AFFECTED IN ANY WAY THAT IS
CERTAINLY NOT WHAT WE EVER WANT
HAPPY NIGHT.
I FEEL LIKE I RESISTED IT THE
OTHER DAY TEN YEARS AGO I
GRADUATED FROM UC RIVERSIDE --
AND AND THE COST OF HOUSING I
CONTINUES TO BE A NUMBER ONE
CONCERN FOR STUDENTS AND SO ALL
WE'RE LOOKING FORCE TRANSPARENCY.
ACCURACY AND THE CONSISTENCY --
THAT EVERY UNIVERSITY PUBLIC
PRIVATE TAKE [inaudible]
YOU'RE SATISFIED.
OKAY GREAT DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND CENTER CERVANTES
EMMA YEAH I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE.
BUT I THINK THAT -- WITH LOOK AT
SEARS IN THESE BASED ON ANALYSIS
I MEAN IT'S DONE TRY ANNUALLY I
THINK THE FACT ALTHOUGH EVEN
THOSE SUPPOSEDLY EVERY THREE
YEARS THE LAST ONES LIKE TEN
YEARS SO THAT.
THAT'S A BIT DISTURBING THE
TERMS OF SAYING THAT THAT SHOULD
BE USED AS THE MAIN BENCHMARK
WHICH I THINK IS. ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THIS BILL.
HIDE IS UPDATE MORE RECENTLY BUT
ONE HEARING FOR THE OPPOSITION
IT MAY NOT BE GRANULAR ENOUGH
RATES OF THE REGION'S VERY LARGE --
AND YOU'RE AVERAGING OUT THEN
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT DEPENDING
ON WHERE THE CAMPUS IS A BABY AN
AREA WHERE HOUSING IS MUCH MORE
COSTLY THAN THE AVERAGE AND
OTHER AREA WHAT.
SO -- YES -- SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
GIVEN WHAT THE OPPOSITION'S
REYES I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS BILL I THINK.
YOU KNOW HOW THE TIDE VARIETY
MUCH MORE RECENT INFORMATION IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S OF PERHAPS
STILL A BETTER BASS LINE.
DO YOU SEE FOR EXAMPLE -- AT AT
IN YOUR BILL PERHAPS.
TREATING SOME KIND OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CAMPUS TO BE
ABLE TO IN THAT BECAUSE THAT YOU
WRITE THESE IT TRIES FINANCIAL
AID A BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS --
AND IN TERMS OF BEGAN TRYING
FRIDAY TRANSPARENCY ACCURATE
INFORMATION -- SOME ABILITY FOR
CAMPUSES TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
USING THE MOST RECENT SEARS TO
THE HEAD OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THAT THAT THAT MIGHT GIVE A
BETTER IDEA WHAT'S LOCALLY I I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DEAL THE GRANULARITY ISSUE THAT
WAS -- I THINK SORT OF RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION AND BY ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT WELL CERTAINLY
THE SURVEY MAY SOUND LIKE IT'S
WHAT IF YOU'RE ONLY DOING IT
EVERY THREE YEARS THE HOUSING
MARKET CAN CHANGE A LOT THREE
YEARS SAYS THE LAST ONE WAS
ALMOST TEN YEARS EVEN THEY
SUPPOSED TO DO.
IT EVERY FEW YEARS IT DOESN'T
SOUND TO ME TO BE VERY VERY
RELIABLE AND SO WE JUST DOING A
PERCENTAGE ADJUSTMENT.
THAT MAY NOT NECESSARILY BE AN
ACTOR REFLECTIONS GOING ON THE
HOUSING MARKET IT'S SO.
I'D MAYBE CAN SPEAK TO FOR YOU
SEE.
DO YOU SEE THE BILL GOING AND
YELLED.
AS A MOVES FORWARD THAT --
MAKING ANY SORT OF WIGGLE ROOM
THERE ARE ARE NOT I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
GIVEN WHAT THE EXPENSE SPECS.
BY THE OPPOSITION HERE NO THANK
YOU SENATOR SO MUCH SO WE
CERTAINLY -- WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND IF
THERE'S A WAY FOR WE CAN ADDED A
PROVISION LANGUAGE AND THAT
WOULD MAKE THEM FEEL.
BETTER IN ADDRESSING THAT
GRANULAR PORTION -- WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN.
CERTAINLY OPEN TO THAT ONLY
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
IS GOING TO POSITIVELY AFFECT
EVERY STUDENT WHEN THEY'RE
DECIDING WHICH CHOICES TO MAKE.
OUR FOR THEIR FUTURE AND SO WE
ARE THAT IS MY FAITH -- MY
COMMITMENTS. TO THE BODY TODAY
OKAY AND AN APPRECIATE SO YOU
BRING THIS BILL FOR BECAUSE I
THINK THAT YOU'RE DRESSING UP
THE REAL PROBLEM WHERE SPECIALLY
IF THERE'S NOT.
WE TALK ABOUT ACCURACY AND SO
FORTH -- IF.
THE SURVEY NEEDS TO BE DONE MUCH
MORE CONSISTENTLY TO WE'RE GOING
TO USE THAT AND EVEN AS AN
ADJUSTER SO -- WITH THAT -- I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON MAYBE
REFINING SOME OF THESE ASPECTS
OF BEHALF IN WAS BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THERE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
ALL RIGHT THE BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES BUT WE WILL KEEP IT ON
CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS.
I THINK I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN OUT THERE COME ON UP.
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM.
FOR AB.
FOR SEVENTY NINE WELCOME BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING AND GOOD MORNING
SENATORS.
THROUGH AB FOR SEVENTY NINE A
PUBLIC CASE THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS WOULD RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT SERVING
PLANT BASED FOOD AND BEVERAGE
CHOICES.
THE BILL WILL ALSO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR STAFF
TRAINING STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
RECIPE DEVELOPMENT AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE NEEDED TO HELP SCHOOL
SUCCESSFULLY SERVE PLANT BASED
OPTIONS.
THIS ACT WILL ULTIMATELY
ACCOMPLISH THE FOLLOWING THREE
GOALS ONE ASSISTS SCHOOLS TO
EXPAND THEIR AVAILABLE FOOD AND
BEVERAGE CHOICES. TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO HEALTHY PLANT BASED
OPTIONS FOR LOW INCOME.
COMMUNITIES AND THREE
ACCOMMODATE STUDENTS WITH
RELIGIOUS OR CULTURAL MEANS. TO
BE CLEAR AB FOR SEVENTY NINE
DOES NOT TELL SCHOOLS TO STOP
SERVING MEAT OR DAIRY.
AB FOR SEVENTY NINE WILL SIMPLY
EMPOWER OUR SCHOOLS TO RETHINK
THE FOOD THEY OFFER TO SUPPORT A
BALANCED DIET -- I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF -- MADAM CHAIR OF FOR
WORKING WITH US TO CLARIFY SOME
OF THE LANGUAGE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OUR A
JENNIFER LE BAR FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND JUDY MANN QUEUE SO
FROM SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL
YOU BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
THERE ARE NONE OKAY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MY LANGUAGE YES
PERFECT THANK YOU SIR.
WELCOME I EACH OF YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LEYVA AND
HIS TEAM MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I'M JENNIFER
LE BAR WITH SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I'VE SPENT THE LAST TWENTY ONE
YEARS OPERATING URBAN SCHOOL
FOOD SERVICE SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS PROVIDE
A RELIABLE AND MUCH NEEDED
SOURCE OF HEALTHY MEALS FOR
CHILDREN.
DUE TO LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS OFTEN ONLY HAVE
A DOLLAR TWENTY FIVE TO PAY FOR
THE ENTREE FRUIT VEGETABLE IN
MILK THAT WE MUST SERVE TO OUR
STUDENTS.
DUE TO THIS WE ARE NOT ALWAYS
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE TYPES OF
FOODS THAT ARE CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE. FOR EXAMPLE WE CAN
AFFORD TO PROVIDE MILK
ALTERNATIVES AS A CHOICE FOR
STUDENTS AND ONE OF VAST NUMBER
OF YOUR STUDENTS ARE LACTOSE
INTOLERANT WE ARE HIS MISSING
THE MARK.
AB FOUR SEVEN NINE WOULD HELP
OFFSET MANY OF THE SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE EXPENSES INCURRED WITH
OFFERING MORE PLANT BASED
OPTIONS.
AND IT WOULD ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND THESE MEALS
WHICH ARE GOOD FOR BOTH THE
CHILDREN'S MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU
TO SUPPORT AB FOUR SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING I'M JUDY MAN CREW
SO PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER IS
SOCIAL COMPASSION AND
LEGISLATION AND A PROUD CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL.
I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
CHILDREN'S HEALTH ACCORDING TO
THE CDC AND NINE OUT OF TEN YOU
AS CHILDREN DON'T EAT ENOUGH
VEGETABLES AND 70% OF CALIFORNIA
KIDS FALL SHORT.
OBESITY RATES AMONG OUR CHILDREN
IS A SHOCKING THIRTEEN POINT 9%
OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT WERE OBESE
WHILE FORTY POLL POINT SEVEN OF
THE ADOLESCENTS ARE OVERWEIGHT
OR OBESE 40%.
AND IT IS PROJECT AT ONE IN
THREE WILL HAVE DIABETES IN
THEIR LIFETIME THESE ARE
SHOCKING NUMBERS AND WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE KIDS THAT DON'T
LEARN HEALTHY HABITS THEY GROW
UP AND NEED LOTS AND LOTS OF
HEALTH CARE.
CHRONIC DISEASES RELATED TO OUR
DIET NOW ACCOUNT FOR SEVEN IN
TEN U. S. DOES 90% 90% OF OUR
ANNUAL THREE POINT FIVE TRILLION
HEALTH CARE EXPENSES.
ARE FOR PEOPLE WITH AT LEAST ONE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITION SUCH AS
OBESITY DIABETES OR HEART
DISEASE -- AS JENNIFER MENTION
CHILDREN ARE LACTOSE INTOLERANT
CANNOT DRINK CALLS MILK TODAY
THEY HAVE NO CHOICE IF A CHILD
NEEDS TO E. PLANT BASED FOR
THEIR HELP ARE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THAT IS THEIR DIETARY CHOICES.
THAT IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THEM HANDS DOWN SO PLEASE HELP
OUR SCHOOLS TO HELP OUR CHILDREN
LEARN AND LIVE HEALTHY HABITS
FOR THAT REASON I RESPECTFULLY
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
CARLOS MACHADO THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
SO AS A NOT AT LAKE HOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT.
AUTOMOTIVE SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT.
LADY ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
CANYON PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
PERSONALLY CLOSE HERE ON BEHALF
HUMANE SOCIETY OF UNITED TATES
AND CITY OF LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT.
HI JANET MCCARTY I WORK AT THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN FOLSOM
CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOR SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU CARRY WITH BEGIN HEALTH
AND FITNESS MAGAZINE ALSO A
RESIDENT OF DAVIS CALIFORNIA
WITH A BIG FAMILY IN SCHOOL VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS THANK
YOU?
HI MY NAME IS NICHOLAS SOCKET
WITH SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION I'M DOING A COURTESY
HOWARD MEMORIAL HOSPITAL IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY THANK YOU.
KAREN NASH REGISTERED NURSE.
FROM ROSE FOR CALIFORNIA MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER A SEVENTH AND
EIGHTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN
CHILDREN WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM IN
EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA LUNCHES.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
VERONICA RAF KIND ANIMAL HEALTH
AND WELLNESS IN SUPPORT.
NOW ALSO BELESKEY WITH ANIMAL
HOPE LEGISLATION AND A PARENT
AND IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER FEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND SUPPORT.
DR HEATHER SHANKMAN CARDIOLOGIST
ON BEHALF OF PHYSICIANS
COMMITTEE FOR RESPONSIBLE
MEDICINE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH BOND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FITTED FOR I MEAN AT
WORK IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HOW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP SUPPORTS THANK YOU.
RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A TRUST
FOR PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
THIRD OF THE DIVINE I'M THE HAVE
A FRIENDS OF THE EARTH ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
Q. ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COME ON DOWN.
WELCOME BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JUST OLD FILLED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION -- IN ADDITION TO
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION.
ALSO HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN NINETY DURING AND
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NEUTRAL IN THE
BILL WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
THANKS TO THE WORK OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS.
WE DO BELIEVE HOWEVER IS
IMPORTANT BE ON RECORD THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS WITH
AMENDMENTS MADE FOLLOWING FIRST
POLICY COMMITTEE.
THAT WE WERE MADE WITHOUT OUR
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSERVE OUR
CONSULTATION.
HELLO PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS TO
FUND IMPLEMENTATION.
WITH THIS COULD RESULT IN A ROLL
OUT OF A PROGRAM THAT IS BIASED
AND PROMOTED BY UNSUBSTANTIATED
INFORMATION BY INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE.
MOTIVES OTHER THAN PROMOTING THE
BEST ATTRITION FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN.
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
CHOICE.
HOWEVER WE ALSO SIX PROMOTE A
BALANCED DIET INCLUDES PROPER
NUTRITION BASED SCIENCE.
WRITERS AND DAIRY PRODUCERS ARE
CRITICAL IN PROVIDING THE
PROTEIN VITAMINS AND CALCIUM OR
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN REQUIRED
DAILY BASIS TO EXCEL IN IN
SCHOOL WE APPRECIATE THE ABILITY
TO CONTACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
IN BETWEEN THEIR OPPOSITION
SEEING THAT WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SEEING AND WE HAVE A MOTION SIR
A SENATOR WILK.
I'M CO AUTHOR THE BILL'S SAW BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT
CAN YOU CAN YOU DRESS THE OF THE
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY MISTER --
FILLED HER I WE HAD WORKED
TOGETHER AND WE HAD TAKEN
AMENDMENTS SO THAT AG WE COULD
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS.
MY GOAL IS NOT TO REPLACE ME AS
I HAD DISCUSSED WITH THEM MY
MICHAEL SURELY WISH TO ENSURE
THAT SCHOOLS ARE OFFERING.
CHOICES TO STUDENTS SO THAT WE
HAVE -- GENERATIONS OF YOUNG
ADULTS GROWING BECOMING BETTER
INFORMED ABOUT.
NUTRITIONAL VALUE AND ALSO BEING
AWARE OF FOOD CHOICES -- BECAUSE
ESPECIALLY IN MANY OF OUR POOR
COMMUNITIES STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF THAT -- AND AND
THIS IS WHERE PRIMARILY THIS
BILL IS TARGETING.
AND AMONGST OTHER THINGS THAT IT
I THINK HELPS IN THE LONG TERM
ADDRESS.
AND AND SO WHEN SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE.
ADDRESSED AND DISCUSSED SINCE
THEN I I DO WANNA SAY BELIEVE
WE'VE BEEN AND CONTINUED
COMMUNICATION -- BUT I GUESS BUT
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE HAVING TO
DO WITH.
VARIOUS SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL -- WHO MAY
RUN CONTRARY TO SOME OF THE
INTERESTS?
THAT THAT THAT'S CONTRIBUTING TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS
[inaudible]
CARE.
THAT'S I HOPE I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION.
NOT REALLY -- SO HE SAID THAT HE
SO IT WAS IMMEDIATELY BE MORE
SPECIFIC QUE THANKS.
YOU CAN.
END UP HAVING MANY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SUPPORT.
A BILL.
AND SOME OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
INVOLVED MAY BE IN DIRECT
CONTRAST THING VIEWPOINT.
WITH FORMER OPPOSITION.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE CONCERN
IS COMING FROM NOT KNOWING
EXACTLY WHAT.
SOME OF THE SET UP OF WITH THE
POTENTIAL PRIVATE FUNDS BEING
USED. TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THIS BILL -- I THINK THERE'S
CONCERN THAT WELL HOW WILL THESE
FUNDS BE USED AND WHAT.
DOCTOR AND WILL THEY BE
UTILIZING THAT IN SCHOOLS EIGHT
THAT'S WHERE THE CONCERN IS
COMING FROM.
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN MAY I
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW WHO EVEN
MAKES THAT DECISION OF SOME WAS
A PRIVATELY FUNDED FOR SCHOOLS
HOW DOES HOW DOES THAT EVEN WORK.
IF WHO MAKES THE DECISION.
BECAUSE IT.
CAN YOU CAN YOU.
COME TO THE MIKE THERE YEAH.
A LOOK AT A YOU WHO ELSE WILL BE
LOOKING.
SHISEIDO.
YOUR GOOD IT'S ON THANK YOU.
SO -- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS IS
THE MAN AND WHAT WAS PUT IN TO
ALLOW -- PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
AND INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE FUNDS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
OKAY TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM.
I THINK OUR CONCERN IS AND I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE EXPRESSED THE
CITY OFFERS OFFICE SENSES
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE.
THAT THERE'S REALLY NO GUARANTEE.
THAT THERE IS WON'T BE -- YOU
KNOW ANY ANY BIAS OR INFORMATION
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY NUTRITION
BASED -- THAT THAT WILL BE USED
TO PROMOTE THAT MOVING FORWARD --
BEYOND -- YOU KNOW THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM IN
THIS PRIVATE FUNDS UTILIZED --
IT'S IT'S JUST A VERY BROAD
PROVISION THAT'S IN THE BILL
THAT SIMPLY ALLOWS THEM TO
ACCEPT PRIVATE FUNDS TO
REIMBURSE SCHOOLS.
THAT CHOOSE -- TO TO USE -- TO
USE THIS OPTION SO I GUESS PART
OF IT IS ALSO JUST THAT THE FOR
THE FACT THAT -- THE PROVISION
IS VERY BROAD WITH REALLY NO
CONSTRAINTS OR FOR OR LIMITING
FRAME FOR LIVING AROUND THE
FRAMEWORK.
THAT PROVIDES US WITH WITH THAT
CONCERN MOVING MOVING FORWARD IF
THE AUTHOR SO INCLINED WOULD YOU
BE WILLING TO CONTINUE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT YEAH I THINK
WE HAVE AND WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE SENSE ABOUT
ARC THAT CONCERNED -- SO FAR
THERE'S NOT BEEN A DESIRE TO
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN BUT IF
THERE WAS AT SOME POINT -- WE
WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO
SIT DOWN AS WE HAVE IN THE PAST
WE HAVE BEEN.
OPERATING AND GO SHOOTING GOOD
FAITHON THIS BILL AND SO I
THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE OPEN TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I DO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S C. D. E. THAT
WOULD MAKE THE DECISION.
YEAH CAT IF THAT WOULD HELP YEAH
JUSTIN SAID THAT OKAY.
GOOD ASSEMBLY SENATOR DRUG SO.
YEAH I I'M NOT SURE HOW TO IF
THERE'S A FIX FOR THIS BUT ONE
THING THAT THE GENTLEMAN SAID
THAT DID.
GET MY ATTENTION IS THAT DOES
THIS BECOME A BIAS -- YOU KNOW
AGAINST OTHER FOODS -- AND I
WOULD BE REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT IT'S ONE THING TO
ACCOMMODATE AND PROVIDE CHOICES
BECAUSE I KNOW WHEN I GO TO
CERTAIN GROCERY STORES AND MY
COMMUNITY.
WE ARE NOT PROVIDED THE CHOICES
AND FRANKLY I DO A MIX OF THINGS
YOU KNOW IT'S A TRY TO GET MORE.
VEGETABLES YEAR IN THERE AND ALL
THAT BUT I DO GET A MIX UP I
LIKE THE CHOICES AND SO I WOULD
WANT THIS TO BECOME THAT WERE.
SLOWLY MOVING IN WITH CERTAIN
FOODS AND A TO THE DETRIMENT OF
NOT OFFERING OTHER FOODS SO AND
I THAT.
COULD HAPPEN I MEAN THERE'S VERY --
SERIOUS OF DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
FOR EXAMPLE A BUDGETARY AND BE
GOOD AND THEN MEAT EATERS SO.
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE BUT I I
APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS IS ALSO ADDRESSING
RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL ISSUES
AND CONCERNS SO.
I'M FOR IT BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION OF THE NINE
OTHER FOODS -- IN THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU SO.
LET ME LET ME JUST.
TRY.
TO GIVE A AS AS SPACE BRIEF OF A
RESPONSE.
PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE WITH THIS IS CHANGE A
CULTURE.
BECAUSE WHAT'S BEEN
INSTITUTIONALIZED OVER TIME.
ARE CERTAIN TYPES OF FOODS THAT
HAVE BEEN -- SUBSIDIZED BY
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND HAVE BEEN INSTITUTIONALIZED
IN THE PROCESS.
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
A LARGE GROWING POPULATION SOME
OF THOSE EFFORTS NEEDED TO BE
PUT INTO PLACE.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT ONCE
THAT HAPPENS.
THEN OVER TIME SOME THINGS ARE
NEGLECTED.
AND SO THIS IS AN EFFORT TO TRY
TO JUST DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE
ARE OTHER OPTIONS.
AND FOR CHILDREN SCHOOL AGE
STUDENTS TO BECOME BETTER
INFORMED ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
CONSUMING.
IT'S NOT EVEN FORCING THEM. TO
EAT IT IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
THEY DON'T HAVE.
TO IT'S BASICALLY.
FOR REQUIRING SCHOOLS AT LEAST
OFFER THE OPTION.
SO THAT THEN STUDENTS CAN BE
BETTER INFORMED AND KNOW FOR
THEMSELVES IF THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE OR NOT.
THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL NOW.
PRIVATELY FUNDING SOMETHING WE
CONSTANTLY DO THAT WE CONSTANTLY
GET INTO PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
IN ORDER BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE NEEDS THAT.
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND SO WE
USUALLY SET UP A PILOT PROJECT
PROJECT AND WE GARNER PRIVATE
SUPPORT SO THAT WE CAN HELP.
MOVE OR ADVANCE A CERTAIN ISSUE
FORWARD THIS IS.
THIS IS BASICALLY DOING THAT
WHAT'S ALLOWING FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN.
MINOR OFFER SOMETHING AS AN
OPERATIONAL POINT OF VIEW OUR
JOB IS TO FEED.
STUDENTS AND IF WE ARE CREATING
A SYSTEM THAT DOES NOT SATISFY
THE NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
THEN THAT'S WHEN WE'RE FAILING
AND SO RIGHT NOW WE STRUGGLE TO
DO THAT INTO OLD EMILY WE'RE
STILL GOING TO BE PROVIDING FOOD
THAT EVERY CHILD WANTS IN THIS
IS ASSISTING US TO MEET THE MARK
WHERE WERE MISSING IT.
AND SO. TO SAY THAT THIS WILL
SUPPLANT OR REMOVE OTHER TYPES
OF PROTEIN SOURCES THAT'S NOT IN
OUR BEST INTERESTS IN IT'S NOT
IN OUR STUDENTS BEST NTEREST.
BUT WE NEED TO ADD TO THAT AND
SO THAT WE CAN DO THOSE
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE.
ITEMS FOR OUR STUDENTS TO MEET
THEIR NEEDS.
I'D LIKE TO ACT AS ONE THING THE
PENDULUM HAS BEEN SWUNG ALL THE
WAY TO ONE SIDE WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO GET IT TO COME.
IT SOMEWHERE EVEN NEAR THE
MIDDLE [inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW AS A VEGAN FOR TWENTY
NINE YEARS.
WE ARE MORE OR LESS
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BY NOT
HAVING FOOD CHOICES SO IT'S JUST
GIVING PEOPLE CHILDREN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT CHOICE
AND TO MAYBE START OFF.
ON THE RIGHT FOOT THAT THEIR
PARENTS WANT THEM TO HAVE THAT
THE DOCTOR WANTS THEM TO HAVE SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR RUSSELL GOOD OKAY
CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU SUGGEST JUST TO
CLARIFY THE PRIVATE FUNDING
WOULD GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND IT'S ONLY TO HELP
PAY FOR THE PLANT BASED DIET
IT'S NOT TO FIGHT AND I THINK
EDUCATION OR OTHER TYPES OF I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
EXACTLY WE SAID PRIVATE FUNDING
WHAT.
EXACTLY ARE YOU YES BY THE
FUNDING FOR IT BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND IN THE BILL WERE
CREATING A FUND TO HELP.
SUPPORT AND THEY HAVE SCHOOL
THIS XP ABLE TO PAY FOR PLANT
BASED.
FOODS BECAUSE THEY MAY COST A
LITTLE MORE FOR SOME REASON --
SO IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THAT
CORRECT IS IN THE THE MONEY
DOESN'T GET ANYTHING ELSE.
RIGHT.
POLICE THE CELL.
NO THE THE WELL THE THE PROGRAM
DOES HAVE A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES AND RECIPES
AND EIGHT SO THAT AND THAT
SINISTER BY C. D. E. S. OKAY.
AND C. E. WOULD HAVE THE CHOICE
TO ACCEPT OR REJECT THE FUNDS
[inaudible]
I YES I WOULD JUST YES I DON'T
HAVE A PRESCRIPTION IT'S NOT
PRESCRIBE WHAT MONEY THEY CAN
TAKE OVER NOT SO.
IT WOULD BE THEIR CHOICE OKAY I
MEAN I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS IS THAT -- CD NEEDS TO
HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO IF YOU RECEIVING FIRE FUNDS
TO MAKE JUDGMENTS ABOUT IS IT
ASKING THE PART OF EDUCATION TO
FOR FORD LET'S SAY I DON'T
THOUGH I KNOW THIS IS NOT THE
DESIRE OF YOUR BILL OR TO
SPONSORS BUT IF SOMEONE SAYS
WELL I'M WILLING TO GIVE A
MILLION DOLLARS.
TO SEE E. SO THAT EVERY SO THAT
STUDENTS SINCE PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OR SOMETHING OR TOLD
THAT.
YOU KNOW MEAT IS POISON.
SO IT'S NOT CONDITIONAL OKAY
THAT THAT'S IF IF I'M UNDERSTAND
OKAY YOUR CONCERN BY IT'S
ANOTHER WITHOUT CD NEEDS ABILITY
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THIS THE
FOREVER PROGRAM WERE EXTEND OUR
FOR MIKE IT TAKING ACCEPTING
FUNDING FROM AND THEN GRANTING.
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS GONNA BE
MEET THEIR STANDARDS FOR
ACCURACY AND AND AND SO FORTH I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S THE NIGHT
STATE COULD BE COMPELLED TO TAKE
EXCEPT FUNDS.
AND THEN HAVE TO TEACH STUDENTS
SOMETHING THAT'S INACCURATE THAT
THE CITY WOULD NOT VIEW IS
APPROPRIATE OR ACCURATE.
I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I AM PRETTY SURE THAT'S WHAT YOU
INTEND I JUST ONE OF THE I THINK
THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT SEEMS TO
BE FLOATING OUT THERE IT'S ONE
BE SURE THAT'S THAT'S CLEAR
RIGHT.
YES CD HAS THE DISCRETION RIGHT
SO THEY CAN ACCEPT THE FUNDS
THEY CANNOT ACCEPT THE FUNDS IF
IF ONE THE CONDITIONS OF THE
FUND IS.
TO PROVIDE AN ACCURATE
INFORMATION IN THEIR VIEW IT'S
AN ACCURATE SO THAT THEY CAN
DECLINE DAY WILL BE ABLE TO
CLIMB THAT.
YES OKAY ALL RIGHT RIGHT DOES
THAT AND I GUESS -- I WOULD ASK --
PDD TWEENER AS IS IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING AS WELL IN THAT
YES I THINK THAT YOU AND I
SHOULD HAVE QUALIFIED THIS
EARLIER AND I MY APOLOGIES I
THINK IT AGAIN IT'S NOT. FOR THE
NECESSARILY THE THE I
REIMBURSABLE OF OF OF THE
PRODUCT ITSELF.
IT'S THE OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE
BILL IT'S THE ADVERTISING ITS
THE EDUCATION THAT GOES ALONG
WITH THAT SO I THINK IN IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU PROVIDED -- YOU
KNOW AS IS PART OF THE DONATION
THAT IS TO CD THAT COMES WITH.
YOU KNOW A TYPE OF PROMOTIONAL
ACT YOU KNOW MATERIAL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IT'S JUST
NOT SPELLED OUT TO I GUESS OUR
TO RELIEVE THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE THAT THERE MIGHT BE -- YOU
KNOW INFORMATION THAT'S THAT'S
DISTRIBUTED WITH THAT PRODUCT
WHICH AGAIN THE INTENT I
UNDERSTAND IS TO PAY FOR THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF THE MEAL BUT
BECAUSE THE BILL GOES BEYOND
THAT.
THAT'S REALLY THE HEART OF OUR
CONCERN I AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT -- OKAY BUT THAT BUT I
THINK AS THE AS I THE AUTHORS
ANSWERED.
CITY HAS THE DISCRETION
THEREFORE TO TO EXERCISE THAT
DISCRETION WHETHER TO ACCEPT THE
FUNDS AIR.
IF THEY FEEL THAT WHATEVER
EDUCATION ADVERTISING GOES WITH
THE SUIT IS AN APPROPRIATE OR IS
INACCURATE.
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO SAY NO WE
DON'T ACCEPT THOSE FUNDS BECAUSE
WE CAN'T ACCEPT THOSE CONDITIONS
[inaudible]
NICE OKAY.
THANK YOU.
YES.
I DON'T WANT TO ELABORATE THE
POINT BUT IF WE WERE GONNA WRITE
BILLS WITH ALL THE INTENSE OF
WHAT WE DON'T WANT SOMETHING TO
DO I THINK THE BILLS WOULD BE.
OF THE VERY PRESCRIPTIVE AND
VERY LONG AND SO THAT SO.
THIS IS NOT TO DISPARAGE IN
ANYWAY BUT IT'S JUST TO SAY THAT
I APPRECIATE WHERE THE CONCERN
IS COMING FROM BUT THAT WAS NOT
THE INTENT.
AND AND AND CITY.
IT THE BILL DOES NOT PRESCRIBE.
WHAT TO DO -- EIGHT EIGHT ALLOW
CD TO TAKE PRIVATE FUNDING IT'S
PERMISSIVE YEAH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU -- I
THINK EVERYBODY FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES -- DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANKYOU A SEVEN MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY AFTER THAT
CONVERSATION I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE I I THINK.
I THINK WE ALL SEE THE VALUE IN
THIS AND I THINK SOMETIMES WHEN
WE ARE PROPOSING SOMETHING A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAT REQUIRES A
LITTLE BIT OF CHANGE.
IT TAKES A LITTLE BIT OF
DISCOMFORT TO GET USED.
TO THE NEW AND AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WITH THAT THANK YOU
SIMPLY MEMBERS THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR TO RAZA MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOR A. B. FOUR SEVEN NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK CHANGE -- ASAL TO
WRESTLE I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN.
ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE THREE VOTES
AND WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
FIVE WELL I'M FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON.
AB.
FIVE FORTY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
FIVE FORTY ESTABLISHES THE CAL
GRANT BE SERVICE INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM INTO THE CALIFORNIA SOON
EIGHT COMMISSION.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT WILL
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE AND GAIN
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR SELECTED
CAREER PATH THROUGH VOLUNTEERING
AND COMMUNITY SERVICES.
THANKS TO ALL WHO RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF DREAMERS BRING TO
CALIFORNIA FUNDING FOR THIS BILL
HAS BECOME A REALITY WITH ME
TODAY IS EVER HE MENACE A YOUTH
ORGANIZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK.
AND DAVID A BRAND GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT EIGHT
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS EVER HUMANE ENDS AND
I AM A YOUTH ORGANIZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK OR CBN.
IT'S AN ORGANIZATION COMPOSED OF
OVER FORTY COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING AND
SERVING AND DOCUMENTS STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND WORKERS.
AS A MEMBER OF THE NETWORK AND
AS AN ORGANIZER HAVE MET SOME OF
THE MOST INTELLIGENT AND DRIVEN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WORK AND
THE FLEA AND TIRELESSLY TO NOT
ONLYATTEND IN SUCH AN
INSTITUTION O HIGHER EDUCATION.
BUT GRADUATED FROM INSTITUTION
OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE REALITY IS AND DOCUMENTS
STUDENTS FACE REAL DAHLE
CHALLENGES BEFORE THEY EVEN
REACH THEIR ADULT YEARS. FOR
MANY STUDENTS ATTENDING COLLEGE
IS NOT A MATTER OF DESIRE OR
WILLINGNESS TO PUT IN THE EFFORT.
BUT A MATTER FINANCIAL COSTS
MILLION DOCUMENTS STUDENTS
WITHIN THE WITHIN THE CITY AND
BALANCE SCHOOLWORK INTERNSHIPS
FELLOWSHIPS VOLUNTEER WORK STUDY
AND A JOB TO BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES THROUGHOUT THEIR
COLLEGE YEARS.
AND FOR MANY OF THEM THE CUT THE
MONEY THEY RECEIVE IS STILL NOT
ENOUGH AND THAT'S BECAUSE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS MANY TIMES
ARE ALSO FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS WHO HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY. TO CONTRIBUTE
AND HELP SUSTAIN THEIR FAMILIES
BACK HOME.
THESE ARE STUDENTS WHO USE THEIR
SUMMER BREAKS TO GO BACK HOME
JOIN THEIR PARENTS IN THE FIELDS.
WORKING FROM SUNRISE TO SUNSET
WHO TAKE CARE OF HER SIBLINGS
AND MENTOR THEM LIKE THEIR OWN
BECAUSE HER PARENTS HAVE TO TAKE
ON A DOUBLE SHIPPED. TO BE ABLE
TO COVER THEIR MONTHLY EXPENSES.
BY VOTING FOR AB FIVE FORTY
WOULD HELP LESSEN THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN OF MANY UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON
THE FUTURE WILL BE ATTENDING
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND HELP THAT STUDENT OBTAINED
THEIR DEGREE.
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS OF A
DOCUMENT STUDENTS AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DAVID O'BRIEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
THIS BILL REALLY JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS.
ARE DREAMERS STUDENTS AND
ORGANIZES FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
IN ADVOCACY ON THIS CRUCIAL
ISSUE WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THAT
THERE WAS SOME FUNNY INCLUDED
FOR THIS PROGRAM IN THE STATE
BUDGET.
AND ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE
SPONSORS ON ANY ADDITIONAL
CLEANUP PROGRAMS THAT MAY BE
NECESSARY THROUGH THIS BILL AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. FOUR THANK YOU
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
FOR SIGNS WHICH ARE THE COLLEGE
OF REMAIN IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ALSO
REPRESENTING OUR YOUTH
ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM NETWORK PROVIDER BE A
SPONSOR AND I'M ALSO HERE FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
I KNOW YOUR FIRST GO WITH
CALIFORNIA JIM NETWORK AND WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WICHITA'S WITH CALIFORNIA JIM
NOBLE IN SUPPORT.
ERICA REMEMBER HAVE THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA GOT THE
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KARAGANDA US ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
IN MY **** ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS IN SUPPORT.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. FORTY HOURS RAISE THE I
CC YOU IN SUPPORT.
CORDY MANY RODRIGUEZ MATTRESS
WAS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SENATOR
AWESOME.
JUST QUICKLY -- I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- WHERE THERE'S A
WILL THERE'S A WAY?
AND IN SPANISH THAT THE IS HE
SAID WHETHER -- BUT ALSO IN
MEMORY AND IN THE SPIRIT OF
MARKEL FIREBALL WHO.
REALLY INTRODUCED THE WHOLE
NOTION IN OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
THAT UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
AND YOUTH AND ADULTS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO EDUCATION.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAW SO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
THANK YOU AND AS THEY THINK IT'S
BEEN STATED AND AND THEY IT'S
NOT LOST ON ANYONE THAT THIS IS
ANOTHER VERSION OF AB -- FIVE
FORTY AND SO WE AS A AS A STATE
HAVE.
CHEN OUR BEST TO SUPPORT ALL OF
OUR SCHOLARS AND ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND A HAT THIS IS BEEN
A THIRTY YEAR A THREE YEAR
EFFORT FOR ME AND VERY EXCITED
THAT THIS YEAR WE SEE SOMETHING
IN THE BUDGET AND EXCITED TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE THIS FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FIVE AB FIVE FORTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHANGE TO ASAL.
WRESTLE I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN PAN
AYE.
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL WITH FILE ITEM SIX SB.
SIX TWENTY FOUR BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PLEASE TODAY TO PRESENT AB SIX
TWO FOUR WHICH WILL REQUIRE
SCHOOLS THAT CHOOSE TO ISSUE
STUDENT ID CARDS. TO INCLUDE
PHONE NUMBERS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HOTLINES ON
THE IDEA.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO ENSURE THE YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE FACING A
CHALLENGING SITUATION INVOLVING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR SEXUAL HEALTH ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS TIMELY AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
THAT MAY BE A CENTRAL TO THEIR
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL WELL BEING.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A REAL AN
URGENT NEED FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION.
STATISTICS DEMONSTRATE THAT ONE
IN THREE TEENS WILL EXPERIENCE
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE ONE IN NINE
GIRLS WILL EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR ABUSE BEFORE AGE.
EIGHTEEN AND S. T. I. RATES
CONTINUE TO RISE AMONG
CALIFORNIA'S TEENS AND YOUNG
ADULTS.
AB SIXTY FOUR WOULD MAKE THIS
INFORMATION MORE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHOSE INTERNET USAGE MAY BE
MONITORED BY AN ABUSER.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF EDUCATION AND
HEALTH GROUPS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S LAW CENTER AND
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION AMONG OTHERS.
WITH ME HERE TODAY -- TO TO
TESTIFY ARE SHALL BE VICE CAMPUS
VIOLENCE PREVENTION SPECIALIST
AT WE'VE.
AND SIGNED A DEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- SIMON VIEW
WITH THE C. B. H. EIGHTY OUT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMITTEE
THEY HAVE A HEALTH.
AGENCIES CBJ REPRESENTS SIDE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES SOME ALSO
PROVIDE SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES UNFORTUNATELY --
MANY CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND A
MISSILE Và OF VIOLENCE.
AND THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION TO YOU --
FOR TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH --
HEALTH.
AND THE IMPACTS OF SOCIAL SOARED
INTO MISS OF VIOLENCE CAN BE --
LONG LASTING AFFECTING IS A
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH WELL BEING
AND ALSO ECONOMICS.
AND ADDITIONALLY STUDENT MAY NOT
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO READ ONLY
ACCESS THE INFORMATION TO HELP
COPE WITH THESE ISSUES AND SO WE
SEE BE HA WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
EFFORTS.
TO BY STEVEN WITH GREATER ACCESS
TO INFORMATION -- THAT PROMOTE
BETTER HEALTH -- MENTAL HEALTH
AND NOW WE ASK FOR YOUR I FELT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE HERE TODAY MY NAME IS
SHELLY VICE I AND THE CAMPUS
FINANCE PREVENTION SPECIALIST
FOR WE'VE SACRAMENTO'S LOCAL
RAPE CRISIS CENTER AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTER.
MY PRIMARY ROLE OUT WE'VE IS TO
EDUCATE AND ADVOCATE FOR
STUDENTS ALL THE WAY FROM
KINDERGARTEN UP TO SENIOR YEAR.
OF COLLEGE -- I HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF TIMES UNFORTUNATELY
STUDENTS WHO DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
RESOURCES ARE UNTIL I STEP FOOT
ON THEIR CAMPUS.
AND EDUCATE THEM AND TELL THEM
HEY THESE ARE YOUR OPTIONS WITH
THE LITTLE NUMBER ON THE BACK OF
THEIR ID CARD THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE THAT READILY AVAILABLE
NOT ONLY FOR THEMSELVES.
BUT FOR THE OTHER STUDENTS THAT
THEY AROUND EVERY DAY.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
WE'RE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS AGAIN JUST IT'S A RESOURCE
THAT ALLOW STUDENTS TO ACCESS
EVEN LOCAL SERVICES WHEN THEY
CALL THAT HOTLINE -- AS WELL AS
REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES THAT WE
ARE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AT LEE ANGELA READ
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SMITH CALIFORNIA
PARTNER STEPPED ON THE MASTER
BALANCE IN SUPPORT.
LADY OF ONE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
PRESIDENT SOUTH ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BROWN RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
COME ON UP.
WE HAVE THE SUPPORT JUST MOVE
OVER ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JEFF PERFECT BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
YOUR MANAGER OF RED BUTTONS
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RAY FOR
NOW I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE.
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO A. B..
SIX TWO FOUR OUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC.
THE INCLUSION OF ANYMORE HOTLINE
NUMBERS REGARDLESS HOW WERE THEY
WILL DIMINISH THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE ONLY NUMBER.
THAT IS NOW REQUIRED ENSUED
IDENTIFICATION CARDS FROM
SEVENTH GRADE THROUGH COLLEGE
WHICH IS THIS IS THIS WHO IS THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE.
NOT EVERY IMPORTANT ASSISTANCE
NUMBER CAN FIT ON STOOD NINETIES.
WITH EACH ADDITIONAL NUMBER
REQUIRED AND STUDENT ID'S ALL
BECOME SMALLER.
AT SOME POINT USELESS.
THEREFORE THE FOCUS SHOULD
REMAIN ON PREVENTING YOUTH
SUICIDE.
SUICIDE AMONG OUR TEENS AND
COLLEGE STUDENTS IS AN
UNPARALLELED NATIONAL CRISIS.
SUICIDE RATES AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE ALMOST DOUBLED IN SEVENTEEN
YEARS.
SUICIDE IS NOW THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR THOSE
AGES.
TEN TO FOURTEEN NEARLY ONE IN
FIVE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED ATTEMPTING SUICIDE.
9% HAVE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE ONE OR
MORE TIMES. ONE IN TWELVE
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE MADE A
SUICIDE PLAN.
EVERY LIFE IS PRECIOUS TO MUST
BE PROTECTED.
ESPECIALLY WHEN MOST WEAK AND
VULNERABLE.
HAVING ONLY THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE ON ID'S
HELPS PREVENT IMMINENT EATH
AMONG OUR YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK
OF KILLING THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHY THE SINGLE NUMBER WAS
PLACED ON STUDENT ID'S WITH
UNANIMOUS APPROVAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WITH UNIVERSAL
SUPPORT AMONG CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES.
THIS ONE NUMBER.
GIVE STUDENTS CONTEMPLATING
SUICIDE AND OTHER STUDENTS WHO
KNOW CLASSMATES THAT MAY BE
DOING SO.
A DEDICATED RESOURCE TO
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS FOR CRITICAL
SUPPORT IN MOMENTS OF CRISIS.
AB SIX TWO FOUR WOULD DETRACT
FROM THIS VITAL LIFESAVING
RESOURCE.
UNDER THIS BILL TWO OR THREE
ADDITIONAL NUMBERS WOULD BE
MANDATED TO BE PLACED ON STUDENT
ID'S.
ALTHOUGH THIS MEASURE HAS THE
BEST INTENTIONS.
IT WOULD UNDERMINE OUR STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO PREVENT YOUTH
SUICIDE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YOUR MEMBERS MY OWN.
IF.
YOU'RE MEMBERS A THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OPPOSE -- AB
SIX TWENTY FOUR MY NAME IS --
GREG BIRDS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
CHANGING THIS BILL FROM WHEN IT
WAS FIRST INTRODUCED.
BUT WE STILL HAVE SOME SERIOUS
PROBLEMS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
FIRST ORGANIZATION A JET OF
CHECKS TO THE AUTHOR GIVING A
PRIVATE ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS HIS CAMPAIGN PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
THE BILL OF THE TO USE THIS LAW
TO PROMOTE ITSELF TO MILLIONS OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THIS BILL WILL
GIVE A LOT OF FREE ADVERTISING
TO ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
THAT IS GOING TO MAKE OTHER
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS JEALOUS I
CAN IMAGINE IN THE COMING YEARS
MANY PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
GIVING MONEY TO POLITICIANS.
IN HOPES THAT THEIR PRODUCT HOT
LINES GET MANDATED IN THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
THIS IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE USE
OF GOVERNMENT RESOURCES WE ALSO
BELIEVE THIS BILL VIOLATES THE
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS OF PRO LIFE
STUDENTS WITHIN PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BY FORCING THEM TO DISPLAY
AROUND THEIR NECKS OR HOLD IN
THEIR POCKETS AND ID CARD THAT
ADVERTISES FOR ABORTION SERVICES.
IN CONTRADICTION TO THEIR
SINCERELY HELD BELIEFS.
AND LASTLY THIS BILL STILL
COMPELS PRIVATE SCHOOLS TO
COMMUNICATE A GOVERNMENT
SPONSORED MESSAGE BY REQUIRING
THEM TO PRINT THE NUMBERS OF
PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS ON STUDENT
NINETIES.
THE SUPREME COURT RECENTLY
INVALIDATED THE CALIFORNIA FACT
ACT FOR THE SAME TYPE OF
GOVERNMENT COMPELLED SPEECH
CALLING IT A VIOLATION OF FIRST
AMENDMENT.
AND THIS BILL IS NO DIFFERENT.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
AUTHOR REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT RELIGIOUS PRIVATE SCHOOLS --
DON'T HAVE TO PRINT THE SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HOTLINE
ON ID CARDS HE RECOGNIZED A
COMPELLING A RELIGIOUS SCHOOL TO
PROMOTE A MESSAGE IT DISAGREES
WITH.
VIOLATES THE CONSTITUTION.
BUT ALL THE GOVERNMENT COMPELLED
SPEECH VIOLATES THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
IT DOES NOT MATTER IF THE SPEECH
BEING COMPELLED AGREED YOU CAN
WRAP IT UP YOUR TIME'S UP.
A AGREES OR CONFLICTS WITH THE
PRIVATE MESSAGE OF THE VALUES OF
THE ORGANIZATION PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE PRIVATE FOR A
REASON.
THE CONTENT THEY GIVE TO THEIR
STUDENTS REGARDING MORAL ISSUES
A BEHAVIOR COME FROM THEM ALONE
AND THE STATE SHOULD NOT BE
MANDATING THESE MESSAGES ON
PRIVATE SCHOOLS OR ANY OTHER
PRIVATE ORGANIZATION AND FOR
THESE RINK YOU.
WE OPPOSE THANK YOU FOR BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT BUT I FIND IT
SOMEWHAT -- OFFENSIVE THAT THE
OPPOSITION DOESN'T THINK THAT
BEING RAPED IS LIFE ALTERING AND
I KNOW THAT WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
COMMIT SUICIDE BECAUSE IT DOES
IN YOUR LIFE BUT I WOULD ARGUE
THAT A PIECE OF YOU AND A PIECE
OF YOUR SOUL DIES.
WHEN YOU ARE RATE SO I DO NOT
THINK ADDING THIS NUMBER TO THE
BACK OF THE CARD WOULD DO
ANYTHING BUT HELP PEOPLE WITHOUT
IS THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
YES SENATOR PAM?
I THANK YOU AND US -- GABRIEL I
WANT THANK YOU FRAME THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION FOR NOW I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION --
HIDE I DO HERE -- A LITTLE BIT
WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS SAYING IN
TERMS OF I THINK THAT THE PRICE
PERHAPS SEVENTY THREE OR FOUR
NUMBERS BUT I DO HAVE TO SAY
HERE THIS COMMITTEE THAT.
I A WOOD BEES DRAWING CONCERNED
IF PEOPLE WANT TO PUT EVEN MORE
NUMBERS ON THE CARD JUST GIVEN
THE SIZE AND DO I UNDERSTAND I I
THINK -- THAT -- ON ON THAT WHY
PRECIADO THE EMPHASIS ON THE
SUICIDE HOTLINE EIGHT THEY DO
THINK HAVING. THREE OR FOUR
THAT'S BY MAX'S THAT'S KINDA
MAXING OUT WERE STAND AT THIS
REALLY GETS TO BE TOO LAW SO --
I I DO AGREE THAT I THINK THE
NUMBERS THAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING --
WOULD BE UP IN THAT LIST -- IN
MY MIND -- SO I AM THAT'S WHY I
SAID I'LL BE VOTING FOR I
SUPPORT THE BILL NOT BE VOTING
FOR THE BILL -- BUT I GUESS I
ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY IS FOR
SOMEONE ELSE AUTHORS ANOTHER
BILL TO ADD A FEW MORE NUMBERS
WE MAY HAVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHICH THREE
OR FOUR SHOULD BE IN ON THE CARD --
I'VE WITH THE THOUGH I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU THAT BOTH THE
EXISTING LAW WHICH INCLUDES
SUICIDE NUMBER AND THE NUMBER
YOU SUGGESTED WOULD BE IN MY
LIST OF THE TOP THREE OR FOUR
DAYS I WOULD THINK SHOULD BE ON
THE CARDS BUT I DO SO I SAY THAT.
I HOPE WE DON'T HAVE A WHOLE
BUNCH MORE PEOPLE SUGGESTING
MORE NUMBERS ON THE CARDS.
THANK YOU THE USER PAN AS
SOMEONE US CENTER DRAWS.
I DO WANT TO AT LEAST.
IN THE RECEIVING END MAKE THE
DISTINCTION IN THE OPPOSITION.
OF THE WITNESSES AND I
APPRECIATE -- THE VERY SINCERE
CONCERNED ABOUT -- SUICIDE I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE BRINGING
THAT TO OUR ATTENTION -- I TOO
AM OFFENDED BY THE OTHER
WITNESSES REMARK SO I I WON A
LUMP IN.
TOGETHER THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHICH I TO CLOSE GET FIT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM TURNER
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS WANT TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THEM --
CENTER OF CENTER PIN JUST YOUR
COMMENTS -- I AGREE VERY
STRONGLY WITH YOU WE HAVE THE
SAME CONVERSATION ACTUALLY OVER.
IN COMMITTEE ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE I THINK THERE -- THERE
REALLY OUGHT TO BE A A LIMIT
HERE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT WHERE
TO DRAW THE LINE IT WAS THINGS
THAT WOULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT.
LONG TERM IMPACT ON FOLKS --
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO THAT'S WHY
WE DECIDED ON THESE NUMBERS AND
NOT SOME OTHERS THAT WE ARE
UNDER -- DISCUSSION WITH SO SO I
AGREE WITH YOU AND I THINK THIS
IS A NICE PLACE TO DRAW THE LINE
BECAUSE HE'S A REALLY SERIOUS
ISSUES THAT.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DEALING WITH
AND THAT'S BORNE OUT BY THE DATA
THAT WE THAT WE LOOKED AT AS
WELL SO I DON'T THINK THIS IS A
GOOD PLACE TO STOP APPRECIATE --
THE SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- APPRECIATE
CONVERSATION ABOUT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION WHICH I THINK IS TO
SPEND -- RESPECTFUL DISAGREEMENT
BUT I DO AGREE -- I DO AGREE
WITH THE CHAIR ON THIS POINT AND
WHAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE
OUT OF THE BILL THANK YOU SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK YOU ARE
COMMITTING TO AMENDING THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU BRING IT UP ON THE
SENATE FLOOR SAT CORRECT. TO
AMEND OUT THE REQUIREMENT TO
LIST MESSICK BOUGHT THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOTLINE CORRECT WHICH
WILL BE INCLUDED ENDS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO SPELL.
BOOKS USUALLY SENATOR RUBIO YES
YES YES CORRECT SENATOR RUBY AND
I HAD SOME SOME WONDERFUL
CONVERSATIONS I THINK WE'RE
WORKING.
TOWARDS EXACT THE SAME GOAL
WE'RE ON THE SAME TEAM HERE
WE'RE GONNA DO WE NEED TO TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL WORKS FITS
TOGETHER EXCELLENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIX A. B. SIX TWENTY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHAIN WRESTLE
LASSELL I'D GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
CAN I YOU HAVE THREE VOTES WE
WILL LEAVE THE ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM.
EIGHT AB.
SEVEN OH THREE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I'M HERE TO WITH MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT TO YOU AB
SEVEN OLD THREE WHICH WOULD
WAIVE TUITION AND CERTAIN FEES
FOR ANY.
EXONERATE WHO ATTENDS IN A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
PRIOR TO TEN YEARS AFTER RELEASE.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK.
AND WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALTHOUGH
SOMEWHAT RELUCTANTLY BUT WE ARE
ACCEPTING THEM -- AN HONOR AND
EXONERATE SOMEONE WHO HAS AND
WHO WAS INCARCERATED.
THAT IS LATER FOUND BY A COURT
ORDER THAT THEY HAD THAT THEY
WILL BE JUST CHARGE FROM
LIABILITY.
IN CRIMINAL CONTEXT THE TERM
EXONERATE REFERS TO A STATE
WHERE PERSON CONVICTED OF A
CRIME IS LATER PROVED TO BE
INNOCENT.
EXONERATES MAY BE RELEASED THE
LAST CARD WITH THE MEMORIES OF
TRAUMA.
FROM BEING INCREASE IN IN PRISON
FOR A CRIME THEY DID NOT COMMIT.
THIS INCLUDES THE LOSS OF USE
OUR DECADES OF THEIR LIFE.
THE BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN SPENT
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION JOB
EXPERIENCE AND TRAINING.
NOT A RESERVE FORCE TO START
OVER. 50% DO NOT REACH THE
INCOME LEVEL THAT THEY ARE IN
BEFORE BEING.
IT BEFORE ENTERING PRISON.
THIS RESULTS IN A AND ONE THIRD
OF EXONERATES BEING FINANCIALLY
DEPENDENT ON OTHERS.
ACCORDING TO THE COLLEGE BOARD
HIGHER EDUCATION COURSE
SPONSORED LOWER LEVELS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT POVERTY AND
INCARCERATION.
THIS BLL WOULD WAIVE TUITION
AND CERTAIN FEES THAT ARE
REQUIRED AT ANY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PRIOR TO TEN YEARS
UPON RELEASE.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
EXONERATING EXONERATED NATION IN
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION.
HIM TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND A
BROAD TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AS
MUST ALL BE ANDERSON ANTHONY
FROM EXONERATED NAION AT A NAY
C. HERNANDEZ FROM HER NOT A
STRATEGY GROUP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HI GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
ONE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HOMONYMS
OB ANTHONY I AM THE FOUNDER
DIRECTOR OF EXONERATING NATION
AND I'M ALSO AN EXONERATE A
STEADY CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
ON WANT TO TELL YOU JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY THIS BILL
IS VERY IMPORTANT RIGHT.
ARM.
WHEN I ENTER SO ALWAYS FRAMED
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND
PUT IN PRISON?
BUFFY TESTING GROUNDS JANUARY --
NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHEN YOU
ENTERED INSTITUTIONS THEY DO --
TAKE TESTS TO SEE WHERE YOU
EDUCATIONAL LEVEL IS AT TO SEE
WHAT A PLACE YOU WANT TO GET
EDUCATION OR WHAT THEY PUT YOU
IN THE JOB PLACE.
I CAME IN READING AT A FOURTH
GRADE LEVEL.
I SET THERE.
I DON'T KNOW MAYBE TWO YEARS
BEFORE I DECIDED TO PICK UP A
BOOK.
ON BUT IT WAS DOING THAT PROCESS
THAT I WHEN I MADE THE CHOICE TO
FURTHER MY EDUCATION EDUCATE
MYSELF BECAUSE I REALIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR ME TO GET OUT.
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO READ THE
BOOKS UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE LAW.
NO WAS GOING ON SO I CAN HELP
SOMEBODY TO HELP ME [inaudible]
ARM.
SUBSEQUENTLY -- MAYBE TEN YEARS
LATER.
I WAS PERSUADED BY -- BUT MY
TEACHER MARKED TO I WAS A
TEACHER'S AIDE AS HE ASKED ME
WHY I HAVEN'T TAKEN THE GED TEST
AND I TOLD I WAS AFRAID TO DO SO.
SO I TOOK THE TEST AND I PASSED.
I SCORED A TOP TEN IN THE STATE.
IT'S GOING OVER NINETY
PERCENTILE IN THE READING AND
COMPREHENSION.
I REALIZE AND UNDERSTOOD THE
EDUCATION WAS MY KEY TO BE ABLE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL -- HERE IN
SOCIETY TO BECOME PART OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING.
AND SO WHEN I CAME HOME I
CONTINUE THAT EDUCATION.
AND IT COST ME TO GO TO COLLEGE
WHO GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE NOT
DID.
I'M NOT DIG GOING OUT TO
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
THE POLITICAL SCIENCE AND ALSO
TOOK PSYCHOLOGY AND ALSO TO
COMMUNICATION.
AND IT WAS THOUGH IT WAS GOING
TO THOSE CLASSES IN GOING DOING
NAY THAT HELP ME. TO BE WHILE
MET TODAY AND EVEN BEEN IN THIS
RAINY HERE TO BE HERE I'M ALMOST
STUDENT.
I'M YOU GUYS STONE I LEARN EVERY
SINGLE TIME THAT I HAVE
OPPORTUNITY COMING.
THIS BILL HERE.
PUSHES THAT OVER TO THE END OF
THOSE IS PART OF MY COMMUNITY.
WE ARE DEPRIVE COMMUNITY WE ARE
COMMITTED SKILLED.
FEB VERY SO ON THAT.
NOT TOO MANY PEOPLE KNOW.
AND SO WHEN WE HEAR THE PEOPLE
HERE EXONERATING THE OFTEN ACTS
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
AND I HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO THE HAS
BEEN SEVENTEEN YEARS IN PRISON
FOR SOMETHING NOT AND DO NOT WAS
AND IS A I THOUGHT I
RESPECTFULLY EX THAT YOU PASSED
HIS VOTE.
NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF BECAUSE I
WOULD DEFINITELY LOVE TO BE ABLE
TO BE ACCEPTED INTO A UC. TO GO
TO SCHOOL. TO TO SOMEDAY MAYBE
BE HERE WHAT YOU GOT
[inaudible]
OF AND YOUR AYE VOTE WOULD HELP
THAT NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF BUT
OTHER EXONERATES SAW RESPECT.
RESPECTFULLY ACTUALLY ARGO.
THANK YOU SIR LET ME JUST SAY
THAT WE WILL LEARN MORE FROM YOU
THAN YOU WILL LEARN FROM US AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TO
TESTIFY YOU HELP MAKE US BETTER
LEGISLATORS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE STATE WHAT ASSOCIATION
CALLED OFFENSE ATTORNEYS -- I
THINK AFTER HEARING OP LET LET
ME JUST CHANGE MY COMMENTS JUST
JUST A BIT -- THIS BILLS REAL
REALLY BYPRODUCT OF WORK THAT
OBESE PUT IN.
SINCE USER HE WAS RELEASED FROM
PRISON ON MY FIRST MEADOW BE.
ABOUT FOUR FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS WORKING ON A BILL -- TO TRY
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS AND DEAL WITH
PASTORAL MISCONDUCT.
AND OB VOLUNTEERS TIME TO COME
UP AND MEET LEGISLATORS TO TELL
HIS STORY HOW BOTH DA'S AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITHHELD EVIDENCE OF
HIS INNOCENCE.
AND IT TOOK SEVENTEEN YEARS FOR
HIM TO GET OUT OF PRISON HE WAS
SENTENCED TO LIFE IN PRISON.
PLUS FIFTY YEARS THE FACT THAT
HE ACTUALLY TOOK EDUCATION K.
CLASSES IN PRISON SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT OP -- ABOUT THAT TIME
LIMIT LET ME JUST SAY THIS AT
THAT TIME.
AND I'VE WORKING CRIMINAL
DEFENSE WORK FOR NOT ONLY THE
LOBBYIST HOUSES IN ATTORNEY FOR
YEARS.
ANY BROUGHT SOMETHING UP TO ADD
IN REAL LIFE AND THAT IS
EXONERATED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED FROM
PRISON RECEIVE NOTHING?
WHEN YOU COMMIT A CRIME IN YOUR
OWN POORLY RECEIVED GET MONEY
YOU GET A PAROLE OFFICER GET
PAROLE SERVICES HOUSING MENTAL
HEALTH?
JOB TRAINING.
ALL THESE SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE
THE OPTION COMMITTED THE CRIME
FOR EXONERATE.
UP TO FOUR YEARS AGO THERE IS
NOTHING PROVIDED -- OUT OF THE
GATE YOU CAN FILE FOR CLAIMING
COMPENSATION TAKES ABOUT FIVE
SIX SEVEN YEARS DIESEL IS OPPOSE
IT.
SUCKED OUT POINT WE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO WORK TOGETHER TO
START ADDRESSING THAT TO CHANGE
THE PRACTICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST BILL THAT
PASSED.
GRACIOUSLY ON THE LEGISLATURE
CALLED OBESE LAW.
AND MADE BECAUSE HONOREES
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SAME SERVICES
PAROLEES.
HE CAN HE STARTED ORGANIZATION
CONVENE EXONERATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY SAT DOWN WITH THEM FACE
TO FACE AND SAID WHAT WOULD WE
NEED MENTAL HEALTH.
JOB TRAINING EDUCATION WE LOOK
TO WHAT OTHER STATES ARE DOING
TEXAS IS THE ONLY STATE RIGHT
NOW THAT PROVIDES EDUCATION FREE
OF CHARGE. FOR EXONERATION WE
SAID THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE LAST THING I'LL ADD IS THAT --
BUT FOR HIS WORK BUT FOR HIM
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION.
THE CITY CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
TWENTY THOUSAND STEPS BEHIND
INSTEAD OF YOU KNOW TEN THOUSAND
STEPS BEHIND.
AND THE ONE THING THAT HE
REMINDED US IS THAT SINCE THE
SEVENTEEN YEARS HE SPENT IN
PRISON AND THEN SAVE THE ON
JOHNSON AND SOME OF THE OTHER
FOLKS THAT WE MEET WITH.
THOSE ARE YEARS THAT THEY'RE NOT
IN SCHOOL THEY'RE NOT LEARNING
THE JOB SKILLS THEY'RE NOT DOING
ALL OF THIS IT'S A WAY TO CATCH
UP AND SO THIS BILL WAS REALLY --
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE.
PART OF THAT PATHWAY AND TO MAKE
UP. TO SOME EXTENT MAKE UP FOR
THE CITY CALIFORNIA TAKEN AWAY
ALL THE YEARS OF THE OF THEIR
LIFE SO.
I'VE SAID THIS JOKINGLY BUT I
ACTUALLY MEAN THIS I WILL HELP
THROW PARADE FOR THE FIRST
EXONERATED GET INTO THE UC.
UNDER THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS A
TESTAMENT TO JUST THERE THERE'S
THE HUMAN SPIRIT AND I CAN'T
REALLY MAKE UP FOR WHAT WE'VE
TAKEN AWAY BUT WE CAN DO ABOUT
SO. FOR THOSE REASONS I ASKED
FOR A SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU YOUR IT WE CAN'T MAKE
UP BUT WHEN YOU THROW THAT
PARADE YOU LET US KNOW SO THAT
WE CAN BE THEIR TAIL.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING HEARING NONE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU AND I AS A MEMBER OF
OUR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TESTIFYING -- AND AND IS THAT
THE CASE WAS SAID -- YOU KNOW A
GRAVE INJUSTICE WAS UNDER NO WAY
WE CAN MAKE IT UP BUT WE CAN TRY
TO DO SOMETHING MOVING FORWARD
AND CERTAINLY I THINK THIS IS
MORE THAN APPROPRIATE -- TO BE
SURE THAT WE PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TAKING THOSE YEARS
OF LIFE AWAY FROM YOU AND OTHERS
ON THE RES -- WE NEED TO TRY TO
GIVE YOU OPPORTUNITIES WHEN YOU
COME OUT AND SO I'M VERY HAPPY
THIS NICE SUPPORT BILL WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BUILT
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN CENTER
DRUG SO.
I I TO WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE'S NOTHING MORE
POWERFUL.
SECOND -- ONLY TO DOCTOR WEBER
IS THE WAY SHE TESTIFIES.
AND I MUST SAY THAT'S A VERY
VERY HIGH BAR AND YOUR YOUR
ABOVE THAT.
SO -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE CENTER DORADO ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WANT TO I WANT TO THANK -- BE
IN ANTHONY FOR WORK FOR COMING
TODAY -- YOU KNOW I I HE WAS
WITH ME THE OTHER DAY BECAUSE
THERE'S A SECOND BILL THAT WE'RE
DOING.
ALL THE ALSO DEALS WITH HOUSING
FOR EXONERATING IN -- AND IT'S
NOT A LOT OF THEM BUT THE IMPACT
OF THAT OF THAT INCARCERATIONS
HAD ON THEIR LIVES IS JUST AN
UNBELIEVABLE.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US CAN
IMAGINE IT'S HORRIBLE TO IMAGINE
BEING INCARCERATED.
IT'S EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE BEING INCARCERATED FOR
SOMETHING YOU DID NOT DO.
AND THEN TO BE LET FREE TO COME
OUT OF AND THEN AND BE GIVEN
NOTHING.
IN RETURN TO BE BROUGHT OUT
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM HAVE LOST
THEIR FAMILIES AND ON ALL THOSE
YEARS.
THEIR SPOUSES HAVE DIVORCED --
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE MOVED AWAY
THEIR PARENTS HAVE DIED YOU KNOW
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS
THAT HAPPEN IN A FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY YEAR PERIOD WELL YOU
INCARCERATED SO YOU COME OUT
WITHOUT A LOT OF SUPPORT AND AS
A STATE WE DON'T EVEN SAY I'M
SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU SEEN
THE MOVIE A WHEN THEY SEE US IF
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT YOU MUST SEE
IT IT'S ON NETFLIX.
IT'S ABOUT THE YOUNG MAN IN NEW
YORK COOL WRONGFULLY CONVICTED
AND SO I ASKED MISTER ANTHONY
THE OTHER DAY.
WHAT ABOUT ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HIT THE THE THE WHO HID EVIDENCE
FROM YOU WHAT ABOUT THE JUDGE
YOU DIDN'T CONSIDER CERTAIN
THINGS WHAT ABOUT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND WITH THE WHOLE IS?
WHAT HAPPENED TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO INTENTIONALLY HELD
INFORMATION EVERY LAST ONE OF
HAS BEEN PROMOTED UP THE LINE?
THE JUDGES NOW AIDED DEALING
WITH THE HE'S ON THE COURT OF
APPEALS -- THAT SOMEBODY ELSE IS
NOT CHARGE OF ALL INVESTIGATION
SO NOTHING NEGATIVE IS HAPPEN TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO INTENTIONALLY
INTENTIONALLY KEPT INFORMATION
WAY.
AND SO WHEN YOU SEE THESE THINGS
IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO THE TO
MATCH AND OUR SYSTEM DOES THIS
AND THEN WE DON'T DO ANYTHING IN
RETURN.
IT TAKES YEARS FOR THEM TO GET
ANY KIND OF COMPENSATION -- TO
BASICALLY REBUILD THEIR LIVES
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO
THAT AND SO -- MANY OF THEM LIVE
WITH THEIR ATTORNEYS HE'S BEEN
ABLE TO SHARE WITH US HIS STORY --
ON A VERY PERSONAL LEVEL AND AND
SO I JUST REALLY THINK THAT IT
THIS TIME WE'VE GOT TWO BILLS
THAT STILL ALIVE THE THIRD ONE
DEALT WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
WILL WILL COVER THAT AND ANOTHER
THING BUT WE GET TWO BILLS.
THAT IS STILL A LOT OF THIS IS
CALIFORNIA IS SORRY.
WE'RE SORRY FOR WHAT TOOK PLACE
AND W WANT TO HELP YOU REBUILD
YOUR LIFE AND THAT'S WHY I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SEVEN OH THREE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. FOR THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAM MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN ZERO THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHIANG WRESTLE TO
WRESTLE AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND SHARING YOUR STORY AND
WE ARE SORRY.
MAYBE EVERYONE ELSE ONCE SAID
THAT BUT WE ARE WAS WRONG.
THANK YOU SIR.
A DOCTOR WEBER YOU HAVE THREE
VOTES WILL KEEP IT ON CALL UNTIL%
WE HAVE MORE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING COME ON UP YOU HAVE FILE
ITEM.
SEVEN AB.
SIX NINETY SEVEN PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY MADAM CHAIR
FIRST LET ME JUST SAY I'LL BE
ACCEPTING.
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE
THREE OF THE COMEDIAN ALICE'S.
WE BELIEVE THAT AFTER THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THERE WILL BE
NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
SUPPOSE THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
COLLEGES. TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHETHER GRANTS
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
STUDENTS RELATED TO DONORS OR
ALUMNI.
AND IF SO REQUIRES FOR THE
DISCLOSURE OF SPECIFIED
ADMISSIONS DATA.
THIS BILL GENESIS WAS BASED ON
THE EMISSIONS SCANDAL THAT
REALLY SHOCKED THE COUNTRY.
WE THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND DATA AROUND HOW
ALUMNI AND DONORS GET ACCESS TO
SOME OF THESE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT RESPECT AT FIVE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THOSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED.
I ALEX GRAZE THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES THIS ONE TO SHARE
THAT WE'VE AT WITH THAT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- WE'RE
ARE REMOVING OUR PRIOR
OPPOSITION WE REALLY THANK WE
HAVE A SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT RUN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING HER NUMBER COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED.
WHICH I TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT FOR US RIGHT VERY GOOD THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
I AM SEVEN EIGHTY SIX NINE SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
I WILL CHANGE TO WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN AYE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE THREE
VOTES WILL LEAVE THAT BELONG
CALL THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM.
TEN AB SEVEN SEVEN SIX BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPTION PRESENT THIS BILL FOR YOU
TODAY -- FIRST OFF LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS.
AB SEVEN SEVENTY SIX THE MUCH
NEEDED MEASURE TO HELP ASSURE
THAT AS HE MOVED TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO EARLY CARE.
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS WE HAVE A
SUPPORT OF AN ONLINE DATA SYSTEM
FOR CHILDREN IN THESE PROGRAMS.
IN SO DOING AB SEVEN SEVENTY SIX
WHO WOULD BUILD UPON THE STATE'S
EXISTING GET INFRASTRUCTURE AND
UP TO ADDRESS THE REDNESS CAP
MANY CHILDREN DISPLAY WHEN
ENTERING KINDERGARTEN.
IT WOULD DO THIS BY NEIGHBORING
SCHOOLS AND TEACHERS TO BE
BETTER INFORMED ABOUT HOW TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE CHAO'S
PATH.
FROM BIRTH ENTRY INTO THE K.
TWELVE EDUCATIONAL CAREER.
WITH ME ARE CLOSELY ANGELA RIVAS
HACKER COUNTY OFFICE EDUCATION
AND OTHER OBSERVER CHILDREN NOW
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU AS A MEMBER KALRA
FEAR LEADERSHIP.
CREATING A UNIQUE IDENTIFIER FOR
PRESCHOOL STUDENTS IS AN
INDEPENDENT INDISPENSABLE STEP
ENSURING THAT THE DATA AND
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN IN
PRESCHOOL FOLLOW THEM ALL THE
WAY THROUGH -- THE TEA INTO THE
TEA CASES SOME AND IT CAN FORM
THEIR EARLY EDUCATION -- AS WELL
AS EARLY ELEMENTARY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA SPENDS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
ON CENTER BASED CHILDCARE AND
DEVELOPMENT.
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN ZERO FIVE
THESE PROGRAMS COLLECTIVE RIGHTY
OF EM INFORMATION FROM ACADEMIC
AND HEALTH -- AT AREAS BUT
THEY'RE ALL THAT BUT NONE OF
THEM LINKED TOGETHER -- AND SO.
IF BECAUSE THE DATA SO
FRAGMENTED WE'RE NOT ABLE TO USE
IT WELL -- LINKING THESE EARLY
SYSTEMS FROM MULTIPLE INPUTS
INTO -- ONE SYSTEM FOR FOR
LOOKING AT LATER OUTCOMES WILL
HELP US TO BETTER SERVE THE
STUDENT AND TWO MORE
APPROPRIATELY DRESSED NOT USING
NEEDS BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT MISSING ANY NEEDS THAT
THEY MAY HAVE.
SERVICE CENTER COUNTY HAS THE
EVIDENCE OF BENEFITS TO OF THE
LINKAGES ACROSS -- THE LEARNING
LANDSCAPE THANKS TO A LOCAL
PILOT PROJECT LED BY SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF IT FIRST FIVE
SANTA CLARA IN A PARTNERSHIP
INCLUDING SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
A COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
OPERATING AB C. FOR A PROGRAM
AND THEN HEAD START FROM TWO
OTHER COUNTIES -- EXCUSE ME HIS
START FROM SANTA CLARA AND SAN
BENITO COUNTY.
AND WE KNOW IT CAN BE DONE AND
WE KNOW IT WORKS -- AB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR THE
TRANSITION FOR STUDENTS FROM
PRESCHOOL INTO THE T. K. SYSTEM.
AND WE WHICH SAYS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MORNING SMITH THE TREND WITH
CHILDREN NOW -- WILL PROUD TO BE
CO SPONSORS ON THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION -- AND
PARTNERING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA -- EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN SIX
IS WELL ALIGNED WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE VISION --
WHICH WAS RECENTLY FUNDED IN THE
BUDGET A CRADLE TO CAREER --
SYSTEM AND IN FACT THIS LEAST
IMPORTANT FOUNDATIONAL -- PIECE
THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO ACTUALLY
HAVE AN EARLY LEARNING DATA
SYSTEMS -- MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED IT'S VERY FRAGMENTED
IT'S NOT -- COHERENT AND
CONNECTED AND THIS INFORMATION
WILL PROVIDE -- IMPORTANT
INSIGHT ON WHERE CALIFORNIA'S
ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES AND
WHAT THE LATER OUTCOMES ARE FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN -- RELATED TO
THAT WHEN THEY GET ACCESS TO
THESE SERVICES -- SO FOR THESE
REASONS -- WE ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL INNOCENCE
SUPPORT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL FOR MOVE BY SENATOR PAN
WHICH I TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YES WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU SIR
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI.
I WILK CHAIN TO WRESTLE.
BLESS SO I'D GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN AYE. THREE VOTES WILL BE
THAT BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
COME ON DOWN YOU HAVE FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MY MENTOR AND
MEMBERS -- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENTTODAY
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONFLICT LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS WITH SB SEVENTY
SEVEN THE EDUCATION BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AND LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT I WILL WORK
WITH LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL TO
ENSURE THE CONFLICT IS RESOLVED.
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVED FORWARD
TODAY.
I BELIEVE THAT IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE EVERY STUDENT HAS ACCESS
TO FUNDING FOR COLLEGE AND COST
SHOULD NEVER BE THE FINAL
DETERMINATION WHEN CHOOSING A
COLLEGE TO ATTEND.
THAT IS WHY I AM VERY EXCITED TO
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN THE COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
ACT.
THIS BILL WILL BRING STABILITY
TO THE CAL GRANT AWARD BY
IMPLEMENTING A NEW WORD FUNDING
FORMULA FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES.
I LIKE THE AWARDS FOR UC AND CSU
THERE ARE JUST THE BASED ON
CHANGES IN TUITION THE AWARD
ALLOCATION FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES WHAT SET TO A
STATIC AMOUNT IN THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND UPON SUCCESS OF
AB.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN CAL GRANT
AWARDS FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES WILL INCREASE AND IT
JUST WITH FUTURE INCREASES IN
ALLOCATIONS FOR THE CSU.
CAL GRANT AWARDS PROVIDE
CRITICAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
STUDENTS AND CAN OFTEN BE THE
FINAL DETERMINATION ON SCHOOL
ACCESS.
NOT ONLY DOES THE CAL GRANT
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE PATHWAY TO
COLLEGE IT SERVES A SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF UNDERSERVED SERVE
STUDENTS.
IN FACT 48% OF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS ARE LATINO WHICH IS
ONE REASON THIS BILL IS A TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN A LATINO
CAUCUS PRIORITY.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT WE INCREASE ACCESS TO
COLLEGE FOR ALL CALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
SO THAT STUDENTS FINANCIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES DO NOT DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN AFFORD
COLLEGE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
TIME TO PRESENT AND TODAY WITH
ME.
I HAVE -- EIGHT A STUDENT FROM
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS STUDENTS
ADDRESS ARRIVE TODAY AND ALEX
GRAVES FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT COLLEGE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITIES. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND
WELCOME UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS
THAT IS MY SCHOOL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SMART VERY SMART A FELLOW
BULLDOG.
WHEN YOU'RE READY?
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
TAKE SOME TIME TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU ABOUT ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN MY NAME'S ON
THEIR SIDE OUT THERE AND WE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FIRST
GENERATION OF UNIVERSITY OF
REDLANDS GRADUATE FROM DECEMBER
TO DENOUNCE.
THIS APRIL I EARNED A BACHELORS
OF ARTS AND COMMUNICATED DECIRTE
DISORDERS AND I AND STRATEGY I'M.
AND I HOPE TO CONTINUE MY
STUDIES STERN EDUCATIONAL
GRADUATE SCHOOL PROGRAM IN
LEARNING AND TECHNOLOGY.
ULTIMATELY I ASPIRE TO BECOME
THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN THE SAM REGINA CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I LIKE IT.
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF AND TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CAL GRANT
STUDENTS ATTENDING INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND OUR
GRATITUDE FOR ALL THE SUPPORT
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED US WITH
THE CAL GRANT AWARD.
WHILE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
SUPPORT WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
FINANCIALLY REFORM MUST INCLUDE
A RENEWED COMMITMENT TO CAL
GRANT STUDENT ATTENDING
NONPROFIT INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES.
THIS IS WHY TODAY WE ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO TO RE ESTABLISH A
CAL GRANT FUNDING FORMULA FOR
STUDENTS LIKE ME WHO CHOOSE TO
ATTEND INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS THE
UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS -- AS A
FORMER CAL GRANT RECIPIENT I CAN
ATTEST THAT THE CAL GRANT WAS AN
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT IN THE
PURSUIT OF AN EDUCATION.
GROWING UP I KNEW THAT I WANTED
TO PURSUE MY POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AT A PRIVATE
INSTITUTION.
I DECIDED TO SMALLER CLASS SIZES
AN INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION BASS
CAMPUS RESOURCES AND WELCOMING
COMMUNITY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS HAD
EVERYTHING THEY DESIRED AND MUCH
MORE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SCHOOL HADA
SEEMINGLY EXPENSIVE PRICE SECOND
HAD ME QUESTIONING IF I CAN
AFFORD IT.
THANKS TO THE CAL GRANT MY
FAMILY AND I COULD AFFORD SUCH A
PROCEDURE EDUCATION WITHOUT
HAVING TO WORK EXCESSIVE HOURS
IN WITHOUT HAVING TO POSTPONE MY
EDUCATION YOUTH TO FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP.
I AM FOREVER THANKFUL TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM AS AS PROVIDED ME
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP
MY PROFESSIONAL SKILLS IT
ALLOWED ME TO GRADUATE A YEAR
EARLY.
AND HAS HELPED ME BECOME WORK
FORCE READY.
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES ARE PLACES OF
INNOVATION INSPIRATION AND ARE
PIONEERS OF EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
TO GO.
ABOVE AND BEYOND TRADITIONAL
BOUNDARIES.
THESE INSTITUTIONS PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PROVIDE ONE ON ONE
ATTENTION FINANCIAL RESOURCES
AND GUARANTEED ON CAMPUS HOUSING
FOR ALL FOUR YEARS.
IN CONCLUSION ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN IS A BILL THAT
IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
NONPROFIT INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY STUDENTS
LIKE ME WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURSUE HIGHER EDUCATION THIS
FINANCIALLY.
EQUITABLE PREDICTABLE AND STABLE
AS A FUTURE EDUCATOR I WANT TO
ENSURE THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF --
BELIEVE THAT SCHOOLS LIKE
RESIDENTS ARE ACCESSIBLE
IMPOSSIBLE PATHWAYS FOR THEM IN
THEIR PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU.
CLEARLY THE UNIVERSITY IS STILL
TURNING OUT GREAT STUDENTS.
GOOD JOB NEXT WITNESS.
ALEX ALEX CASE THAT THE ICY CO.
I I I ALWAYS TELL OUR STUDENTS
ARE BEST ADVOCATES I THINK
THAT'S VERY EVIDENT TODAY -- ALL
I WOULD ADD IS THAT YOU KNOW OUR
SECTOR PROVIDES TREMENDOUS
REGIONAL ACCESS WE'VE EIGHTY
FOUR INSTITUTIONS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE AS WELL AS A NUMBER OF
ONLINE AND ON AND PROGRAMS AND
SATELLITE CAMPUSES -- THEY ALSO
PROVIDE YOU KNOW -- ON AVERAGE
TO CALGARY SIGNALS NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
INSTITUTIONAL A THAT THAT'S DO
NEVER HAS TO PAY BACK.
AND YOU KNOW FOR PLACE BOUND
STUDENTS WERE LOOKING AT THAT
POPULATION WE WE JUST WANNA
ENSURE THAT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SCHOOL --
THAT IS THE BEST FIT FOR THEM
LIKE AN ANDREAS CASE -- YOU KNOW
AND IT ALSO FITS THEIR GOALS
ASPIRATIONS FOR WHAT THEY'RE
HOPING TO DEAL.
AN INSTANCE CONSIDER COLLEGE WE
JUST WANNA ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
TREATED EQUITABLY -- AND THAT
THERE IS STABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY TO SUPPORT THEM
IN THAT IN THAT PURSUIT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION -- HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WOULD ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
WITH CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DAVID O'BRIEN CALIFORNIA'S TO
MAKE COMMISSION ADMINISTRATORS
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM IS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERICA REMAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
PLEASE A CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT.
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SINGER
THIRTY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING MEMORY BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST
HOPE I'M SORRY I DIDN'T CATCH
THAT I.
ONE THANK THE AUTHOR -- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'VE -- HERE IN
THEIR BEEN TRYING TO SUPPORT
OVER MANY YEARS DID ON A JOINT
OP ED SIX YEARS AGO AND
SACRAMENTO BEE -- ON THE SUBJECT
AND I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THIS IT IS IT IS.
IT SHOULD BE HAVE ACCESS IN THE
SAME WAY IN HIGHER EDUCATION
WE'RE REALLY GETTING DOWN TO
MORE PARTICULARS OF WHATWE'RE
GOING TO DO IN OUR LIVES AND TO
HAVE THAT.
ABILITY TO PICK CAMPUSES FOR
WHATEVER REASON SO GO SAINT
MARY'S GAELS ADD.
A VERY CLOSE SECOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PLEASE CLOSE YES
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND AND YOU'RE
CORRECT I I THINK THAT --
EVERYBODY DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO GO WHERE THEY
THEY ARE AND I WHEN I TALK TO
STUDENTS ALWAYS TALK ABOUT YES
IT IS WHAT YOU KNOW BUT IT'S
ALSO WHO YOU KNOW AND THE
ABILITY TO CALL WHAT TO WHATEVER
UNIVERSITY ONE GIVES YOU THE
ACCESS TO THE PEOPLE.
BUT PEOPLE THEIR LIKE MINDED AND
NOT NECESSARILY A BARRIER
BECAUSE YOU CAN AFFORD IT SO
WITH THAT I THINK YOU AND I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
HI LEYVA AYE WILK.
CHANGE CHIANG I'D WRESTLED WITH
US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WE BELIEVE
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL YOU
HAVE FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN OH THREE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB THIRTEEN OH THREE ALLOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE AN
ASSESSMENT FOR THE USE OF
RECREATIONAL SPACE SUCH AS
ATHLETIC FIELDS TRACK AND FIELD.
TENNIS COURTS AND IT OUTDOOR
BASKETBALL COURTS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
A FIVE YEAR.
SUNSET ON THE AUTHORITY TO
CHARGER A PROPOSED A
PROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE COSTS
FOR THE USE OF SCHOOL FACILITIES.
AND GROUNDS.
LISTING Là AUTHORIZES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO CHARGE AN AMOUNT
NOT TO EXCEED DIRECT COSTS FOR
THE USE OF ANY SCHOOL FACILITIES
SUCH AS UTILITIES AND JANITORIAL
SERVICE.
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY DIRECT COSTS ALSO
INCLUDE THE SHARE OF THE COSTS
FOR MAINTENANCE.
REPAIR AND RESTORATION FOR THE
USE OF ANY NON CLASSROOM AREAS
THIS IS WHAT THE SIX TO KEEP
GOING.
KEEP DOING -- EXCESSIVE WEAR AND
TEAR RESULTS IN INCREASED COSTS
TO MAINTAIN AND REPAIR GROUNDS.
JUST LIKE THE THEM JUST LIKE THE
MORE MILES YOU PUT ON A CAR.
THE SOONER YOU WILL NEED TO TAKE
A CAR IN FOR MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIRS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SHARE FACILITIES
FOR COMMUNITIES COVER COMMUNITY
USE WHILE ENSURING THAT OUR K.
TWELVE STUDENTS ARE ALE TO
ATTEND P. CLASSES AND CULTIVATE
SCHOOL SPIRIT.
THROUGH SCHOOL -- THROUGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL OR BASKETBALL TEAMS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
THERE ARE COUPLE WITNESSES HERE --
MADAM CHAIR VERY SIMPLY THIS IS
ODD WERE SEEKING TO CONTINUE IN
EXISTING PROCESS.
THAT'S GOOD THANK YOU SIR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PERCY WHEN YOU'RE
READY I'LL LET YOU GUYS DECIDE
WHO GOES FIRST ERROR BUT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
THINK HE'S COVERED THE BILL
THOROUGHLY JUST WANT TO SIMPLY.
ADD -- THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SUPPORT THE GOALS AND PURPOSES
THE CIVIC CENTER ACT THAT THE
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THE THE
SCHOOLS ARE THE CENTER OF THE
COMMUNITY WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN
FOR DECADES.
WE LOOK YOU KNOW SCHOOLS ARE
LOOKED AT AS A CENTER IN CASE%
THERE'S A DISASTER BUT ON A
POSITIVE NOTE THERE ALSO THERE
FOR THE THE SPORTS AND THE YOUTH --
THE SPECIAL PROGRAMS -- AND EVEN
SOME OF THE SPECIAL EVENTS THAT
ARE OCCURRING IN THE COMMUNITY.
AS THE ANALYSIS -- CORRECTLY
INDICATES THE CIVIC CENTER ACT
DOES REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
MAINTAIN THE FACILITIES AND
CLEAN SAFE CONDITION.
AND SUBJECT SCHOOL DISTRICTSTO
LIABILITY FOR ANY INJURY FOR
FAILURE. TO MAINTAIN THOSE
FACILITIES ARE GROUNDS WITH
BUDGET STRESSES AND CONSTRAINTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS STILL COULD
INCUR OVER ALL THESE YEARS
MAINTENANCE OPERATION BUDGETS
HAVE NOT YET FULLY RECOVERED.
AND BUILDING GROUNDS CONTINUE TO
FALL SHORT OF THE NECESSARY
MAINTENANCE WHEN YOU ADD IN AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER INDICATED
THE ADDITIONAL TIME IN THE WEAR
AND TEAR CREATED BY ALL THE
YOUTH SPORTS IN THE COMMUNITY
ACTIVITIES.
THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN
THOSE FACILITIES AND TO AVOID
THE POTENTIAL LIABILITY.
WE THINK THIS BILL IS A
REASONABLE APPROACH YEAH IT
HERE'S TO THE INTENT AND PURPOSE
OF THE CIVIC CENTER ACT FOR THAT
REASON WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS OR
PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE -- REALLY
COVER THE BILL I EXTENSIVELY THE
ONLY THING I WOULD LIKE TO ADD
IS THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE TELLING
US THAT.
THEY'RE GETTING MORE MORE
REQUEST TO USE OUR FACILITIES
AND SO THE DEMAND IS EVEN
INCREASING THAT THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO HELP
MAINTAIN THE SITES.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
BOGUS SHILOH WOULD LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CHIANG WHICH I TO CLOSER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL RIVAL
MANAGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CHIANG MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THIRTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN OH
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FLOOR LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES GET
OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE IN SENATE EDUCATION
LOOKING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA.
WHEN WE DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHILE WE'RE WAITING?
ON CONSENT WE HAVE ITEM ONE AB
SIXTEEN RIVAS THREE OF US ITEM
TWELVE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO
FRAZIER CONSENT AS AMENDED ITEM.
ELEVEN AB EIGHT FORTY TWO BY
LIMON WE HAVE A MOTION THE
CONSENT KELLER HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAN MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE
CHANGE CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
CAN I VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COOLEY THEN ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WHEN WE LIVED CALLS ON
SOME OF THE BILLS THAT SOME
FOLKS MAY HAVE MISSED -- MADAM
SECRETARY WILL LET YOU BEGIN.
ITEM TWO AB TWO FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
HI JANE I GLAZER MCGUIRE.
WE BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL.
ITEM THREE EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
MONNING AYE VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHANGE.
CHANGE I GLAZER MCGUIRE.
WE WOULD THAT THE PHONE CALLS
WHILE.
ITEM FOUR AB FOUR SEVEN NINE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D GLAZER MCGUIRE.
THE BULLY THAT BILLING CALLS
WELL.
ITEM FIVE AB FIVE FORTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK NO WILK NO
CHANGE [inaudible]
GLAZER MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL.
ITEM SIX AB SIX TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR HASN'T VOTED THREE ZERO
WILK.
NOW WILL CANNELLA CHIANG
[inaudible]
GLAZER MCGUIRE.
THAT BILLING CALLS WELL.
ITEM SEVEN AB SIX NINE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR OF HASN'T
VOTED THREE ZERO WILK NO WILK NO
CHIANG.
GLAZER MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN OH THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
ITEM NINE A. B. SEVEN TEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHANG.
CHIANG AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE.
WILL BE THE BILL ON CALL.
ITEM TEN EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I
CHIANG.
CHANGE I GLAZER MCGUIRE LEAVE
THAT BELONG CALL [inaudible]
HAVE.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
FOR ZERO WILK HI WILK I GLAZER
MCGUIRE.
BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL.
ALL RIGHT AND WE'VE GONE TO THE
ROLE STILL WAITING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
[inaudible]
OKAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WELCOME YOU HAVE
FILE ITEM.
SIXTEEN AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THE MAN CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF OF
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR I WANT
TO FIRST US BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES TECHNICAL.
AMENDMENT AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AT THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA'S TO NEED COMMISSION
TO EXTEND FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATION DEADLINES BY THIRTY
DAYS FOR STUDENTS TO NATURAL
DISASTERS.
OR EMERGENCIES I THINK THIS IS A
SOUND APPROACH. TO PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO THIS TO NAY
COMMISSION WHEN WE HAVE THINGS
LIKE WILD FIRES OR OR OTHER WHAT
OTHER INCIDENTS THAT DON'T ALLOW
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE -- TO APPLY
AS THEY NORMALLY WOULD FOR
FINANCIAL AID -- WE DID SEE FOR
EXAMPLE IN -- PARADISE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT A 38% DECREASE
IN FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS --
COMPARED TO PREVIOUS YEARS I
THINK THIS IS A SOUND AND
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS GET THAT
FINANCE EIGHT IF THEY NEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE
ON AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FOUR I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY DAVID O'BRIEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND ALMA
BUT AT US REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
EXCELLENT PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THE MORNING TURN MEMBERS ON
ABOUT US ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL -- FROM STATE WITH
RESPECTIVE THE SUPERINTENDENT
BELIEVES IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
PROVIDE RELIEF TO STUDENTS WHO
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO SUBMIT THEIR
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS BY
THE STATUTORY DEADLINE DUE TO
UNFORESEEN.
UNFORESEEN EVENTS -- BEYOND
THEIR CONTROL.
AND OUR SUCCESS FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THINK PHONE AND BONTA
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING DAVID O'BRIEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S TO MAKE
COMMISSION WERE SUPPORTING THIS --
COMMONSENSE BILL WHICH PROVIDE
WHICH IS THE SOME MEMBERS SAID --
PROVIDE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THE
EVENT THAT EVENTS OUTSIDE OF
STUDENTS CONTROL AND HE WITH
THEIR ABILITY TO APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID BY THE STATE
STATUTORY DEADLINE -- HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I COULD MORNING KARAGANDA ALICE
ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
AS HIS MERCIES READY MIND RIGHT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
IMAM IMAM MAJID ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS IN SUPPORT.
MAY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTE RESPECT THE ASK THE IVR
THANK YOU SIR.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAM AND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL I
GLAZERS.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
PAN PAN.
YOU HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
YOUR BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ON CALL.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU STAFF THANK YOU.
WELCOME SENATOR GLAZER HOW ABOUT
IF WE LIFT -- CALLS ON THE BILLS
THAT YOU HAVEN'T HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON MEN
SECRETARY.
ITEM TWO AB TWO FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE
ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM THREE ABIES FOR SIXTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING AYE
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM FOR A. B.FOUR SEVEN NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SURE VOTING I FIVE
ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM FIVE AB FIVE FORTY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING NO --
THREE ONE CHIANG GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM SIX AB SIX TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE FOR
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I AM VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO CHIANG GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM SEVEN AB SIX NINE SEVEN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
THREE ONE CHANGE.
CHANG I GLAZER [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN OH THREE
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE I'M WITH.
HIGHER.
ITEM NINE EIGHTY SEVEN TEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM TEN A. B. SEVEN SEVEN SIX
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM.
FIFTEEN AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ESTABLISHES A SCHOOL
PAVEMENT TO PARKS GRANT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE SCHOOLS FUNDING FOR
CONVERTING PORTIONS.
OF THEIR PAVEMENT ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS INTO LIVING SCHOOL YARDS
AND GARDENS.
PARTICIPATING SCHOOLS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT
INCORPORATES SCIENCE MATH
LITERACY AND ATTRITION FOR THEIR
STUDENTS.
SCHOOLS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
PARTNER WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
OR FEDERAL AGENCIES TO MATCH THE
STATE GRANT MONEY.
PRIORITY WILL BE GIVEN TO
SCHOOLS WITH POOR AIR QUALITY
AND HIGH AMOUNTS OF STUDENTS ON
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH.
OUR MEMBERS POOR AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS NUMEROUS COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
IN LA ALONE THERE OVER ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS THEY'RE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO HEALTH ISSUES DUE TO POOR AIR
QUALITY.
EXPERTS TEACHERS AND PARENTS ALL
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROVIDING CHILDREN WITH ACCESS
TO PARKS AND GREEN SPACES.
THOSE BENEFITS INCLUDE IMPROVED
PHYSICAL FITNESS REDUCE VIOLENCE
SYMBOL LANE AND INSPIRING
CRITICAL THINKING AND PROBLEM
COPPENS COMPETENCY IN SCIENCE
LANGUAGE AND LITERACY MATH
CONSTRUCTION.
ENGINEERING.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HELPS
ADDRESS SEVERAL OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRIORITIES IN ONE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IT HELPS THE STATE
INVESTING DISADVANTAGE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
HELPS THE STATE ACHIEVE ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS AND REDUCTION
GOALS.
AND TEACHES CHILDREN ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF AGRICULTURE AND
WHERE FOOD COMES FROM.
THIS BILL WILL BRING NATURE TO
CHILDREN AND MAKE IT AN
EDUCATIONAL JOYFUL AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THEIR DAILY LEARNING --
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
HAVE RECALL MUSTER NOT ALL FROM.
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LANDS.
IS FOR SEED.
A GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THREE
COMMA STRAIGHTENED OUT -- WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND.
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
THIS IS A REALLY VISIONARY BILL
pAND AWAY IT'S SIMPLE BUT ON IN
MY MIND'S CAN SCHOOL YARD
CONVERSIONS ARE THE LAST
FRONTIER OF CARE OF WHICH
ACHIEVING -- ACCESS TO GREEN
SPACES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WE THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND HAS BEEN DOING THIS
IN NEW YORK CITY FOR TWENTY
YEARS -- WE CONFRONTED THE SAME
PROBLEM -- ACQUIRING PARK SPACE
IN NEW YORK CITY IS
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR NGOS AND ON
A COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. TO TO
ACQUIRE PARK SPACE.
AND YET IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
PART POOR PLACES ON IN THE
COUNTRY AND SO IS CALIFORNIA --
WE COULD ACHIEVE ACCESS THROUGH
SCHOOLYARD CONVERSIONS WE HAVE
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK CITY THAT HAVE ACCESS
THAT DIDN'T BECAUSE WE CONVERTED
TWO HUNDRED SCHOOL YARDS AND TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY YEARS -- AS
MEMBER RIVAS MENTIONED THIS HAS
MULTIPLE BENEFITS CLIMB AT YOUR
MITIGATING HEAT ISLANDS YOU CAN
CONVERT THESE BLACK TOPS IN
CONCRETE WITH PERMEABLE SURFACES
YOU CAN CAPTURE STORM WATER
WON'T BE SO PLOT A PRONE TO
FLOODING -- AND AGAIN YOU'RE
TEACHING CHILDREN ON GIVING THEM
AN ENTREE INTO A AND TO THE
NATURAL WORLD WHICH IS.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WE WE ARE
COUNTING ON YOUNG PEOPLE TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND THEY SHOULD GET GOING ON
THAT AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE SO I
REALLY WANT TO THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS AN ARCHER
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
COME ON DOWN.
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE BRANDING GRCIA ON
BEHALF OF THE MUSIC AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION **** COMMITTEE
NATURE CONNECTION LOS ANGELES
NEIGHBORHOOD MATTRESS IN FRONT
OF THE LA RIVER IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
PERSONAL COULD US HERE ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN FROM AROUND HALF THE
COUNTY IN A FIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FLEXIBLE
EDUCATORS AND FROM SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MICHELLE WRASSE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DRAW SO ASSEMBLY WILL
MUCH LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU YOU
KNOW RIGHT BEFORE THIS
PRESENTATION I WAS HAVING A
BRIEF CONVERSATION WITH RICO --
AND REMEMBERING HOW AS A KID
THEY WOULD KEEP US IN OUR
CLASSROOM BECAUSE IT WAS TOO HOT
OUTSIDE AND WE JUST HAD PAVEMENT
THERE WAS NO SHADE OF TREES.
NO ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE ON OUR
SCHOOL YARD SO JUST REMINDED ME
OF WHY I'M DOING THIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THAT'S A GOOD MEMORY AS TO WHY
WE SHOULD BE DOING THIS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR TO ROSWELL MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WILK.
HI WILK I CHIANG CHIANG I'D
RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
CENTER REQUIRE.
THANK YOU.
SIR MCGUIRE WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOU JOIN US IN SENATE BID
THANK YOU SIR PAN THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS A WHICH ITEM.
THIRTEEN START WITH ITEM
THIRTEEN CENTER GLAZER.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN OH
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE FOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO
GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING AYE
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HE SAID.
AND THEN WE HAVE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE FIVE ZERO
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
PLEASE ENTER GLAZER
ON BILLS.
ITEM TWO AB TWO FIVE EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO FIVE
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
ITEM THREE A. B. FOUR SIX THREE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
WHICH ONE ITEM TO AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT AM ITEM TO AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT IS ALSO OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM FOR A. B. FOUR
SEVEN NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE.
BUT BILLS UP.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM FIVE AB FIVE
FORTY THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR VOTING NO.
FOUR ONE MCGUIRE -- CHIANG
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE THAT PULLS
OUT.
FIVE ONE ITEM SIX AB SIX TWENTY
FOR THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I VICE CHAIR THIRTY NO FOUR ONE
CHIANG MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE ONE ITEM SIX EIGHTY SIX
NINE SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I BY SURE
VOTING NO -- FOUR ONE GLAZER
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE FILLS UP.
FIVE ONE ITEM EIGHT AB SEVEN OH
THREE THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AT THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN TEN THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AT THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM TEN A. B. SEVEN
SEVEN SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS AT
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN OH THREE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE FOR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
ICE.
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SEVEN ZERO THAT PULLS OUT.
ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN OH
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FOR THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU EVERYONE BUT
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SORRY --
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN ADOPTED WITH THAT THANK YOU
EVERYONE THE SENATE.
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
STANDS ADJOURNED